wir werden sehen wie es beim nächsten
Einzelplan aussieht Einzelplan 06 ich
schätze allerdings da wird es weniger
Einstimmigkeit geben es geht nämlich um
den Einzelplan von bundesinnenministerin
Nancy fazer also für das Ministerium
Inneres und
Heimat insgesamt soll es jetzt laut dem
Entwurf 13,09 Milliarden Euro geben für
diesen Einzelplan das sind etwa 12 %
weniger 12,6 % weniger als in diesem
Jahr und dafür gab es auch schon Kritik
von der Union die
kritisiert hat dass hier diese
Ankündigung die notwendigen Maßnahmen in
unserem Land gefährden so hieß es sei
jetzt nicht die Zeit um in den Bereichen
bevölkerungs- oder Katastrophenschutz im
Bereich innere Sicherheit oder auch im
Sport den dicken Rotstift zu zücken so
hieß es von Seiten der CDU CSU denn
natürlich viele Menschen leiden sowieso
gerade unter den Preisen und dann ist es
natürlich besonders bitter wenn dann die
Sportstätte vielleicht sogar auch
schließen muss weil es nicht genügend
Geld gibt
eine Dauer von 90 Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die Aussprache das Wort hat
Dr andre berghäcker für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und andere berghaiger
ist auch der Berichterstatter für diesen
Einzelplan im Haushaltsausschuss
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
zum Abschluss der parlamentarischen des
parlamentarischen Verfahrens debattieren
wir hier und heute den Etat des
Einzelplans 06 das Innenministeriums
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin Feser schön
dass sie aus Katar wieder zurück sind
bei andere Gelegenheit würden mich noch
mal ihre Eindrücke von dort
interessieren aber das ist glaube ich
ein separates Gespräch mal wert vielen
Dank an Sie und Ihr Haus für die
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit der Dank
geht natürlich auch an die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Berichterstatter das waren
glaube ich gute Gespräche aber sehen Sie
es mir nach dass die politischen
Bewertung bei der Beantwortung der
Fragen noch auseinander gehen so ist es
nun mal in unsere in unserer Diskussion
wir leben in Zeiten außergewöhnliche
Herausforderungen natürlich auch für den
Bundeshaushalt das ist gar keine Frage
ein Haushalt ist aber für mich immer
eine Frage von Generationengerechtigkeit
und Respekt gegenüber dem Steuerzahler
wichtig ist in diesen schwierigen Zeiten
haben wir Schwerpunkte zu setzen
als Union sind wir da glaube ich völlig
klar wir wollen den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland stärken die äußere
Sicherheit ausbauen und natürlich
korrespondierend die innere Sicherheit
ausbauen da steht außer Frage wir wollen
als Staat nach innen unabhängiger und
resilienter werden besser vorbereitet
sein auf schwierigste Situationen das
ist die zwingende Kehrseite der Stärkung
der äußeren Verteidigung dabei sind für
uns glaube ich alle einig dieser
Einzelplan 06 spielt dabei eine zentrale
Rolle er wächst im parlamentarischen
Verfahren um 330 Milliarden 330
Millionen Euro auf gut 13 Milliarden
Euro leider aber sehr geehrte Ministerin
aus meiner Sicht aus unserer Sicht an
den falschen Stellen
er wird den Erfordernissen der Stärkung
der zivilen Verteidigung des
Bevölkerungsschutzes der inneren
Sicherheit nicht gerecht
ich bin der festen Überzeugung dass die
Ampelkoalition hier zu spät und auch
deutlich zu kurz zu springend warum zu
spät wir alle kennen noch dass warntag
Fiasko aus 2020 die Frage wie
organisieren wir die Auswirkungen der
corona-pandemie die Flutkatastrophe im
Aartal 2021 die Waldbrände in
verschiedenen Regionen in Deutschland
der kürzliche Ausfall der
funkinfrastruktur der Bahn die
Herausforderung zu Unterbringung von
Kriegsflüchtlingen um nur einige
Beispiele zu nennen darauf müssen wir
Antworten haben und zwingend reagieren
und der Regierungsentwurf der sah
tatsächlich deutlich Kürzungen vor im
Bereich der Bundespolizei des BBK des
Bundesamtes für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe und des THW aus meiner
Sicht ein sehr unglückliches Signal nach
außen um das Wort fatal zu vermeiden
wir alle haben doch in unseren
Wahlkreisen gespürt und die Hinweise
bekommen das insbesondere beim THW und
seiner 668 Ortsverbände die Unsicherheit
das Unverständnis und vielleicht auch
die Enttäuschung über diesen Etat
Entwurf riesengroß waren
das hat die Ampel im parlamentarischen
Verfahren bemerkt und versucht zu
korrigieren aber es bleibt bei einem
Versuch sie springen viel zu kurz sie
versuchen den ungenügenden
Regierungsentwurf in diesem Punkten zu
korrigieren zugegebenermaßen nach dem
Gesprächen und Beratungen sie haben die
Mittel beim THW aufgestockt aber der
Ansatz bleibt noch deutlich hinter dem
Ansatz aus dem Jahr 2022 zurück für das
BBK geht vergleichbares und bei der
Bundespolizei sind sie noch weiter
gegangen sie haben zwar die Ansätze im
parlamentarischen Verfahren verändert
Aufstockungen an einigen Stellen
Abstufungen an anderen Stellen aber
unter dem Strich haben sie die Mitte der
Bundespolizei weitergekürzt und obwohl
sie doch wissen dass es hier riesengroße
mehr Bedarfe gibt und die gut angelegten
Gelder dort sinnvoll gebraucht werden
wir haben im Ausschuss und in dem
berichterstattergesprächen formell
informell viele Details besprochen gar
keine Frage ich glaube verstehen sollte
doch wir wollen eng an der Seite
derjenigen stehen die gerade in
schwierigen Lagen unser Land stützen und
der Bevölkerung helfen lassen sie uns
alles alles was vertretbar ist tun um
der Bundespolizei dem THW und dem BBK
den Rücken zu stärken wir als Union
haben in der Bereinigungssitzung für
Katastrophenschutz Bevölkerungsschutz
und der Bundespolizei über eine halbe
Milliarde Euro mehr bereitstellen wollen
um Schwerpunkte zu setzen und Kürzungen
zu minimieren rund 70 Änderungsanträge
inklusive deckungsvorschläge haben wir
eingebracht und wir halten bis heute
unter anderem an dem Antrag für
Maßnahmen zur Bewältigung eines
flächendeckenden Stromausfalls fest und
fühlen uns dabei durch die jüngsten
Diskussionen und Äußerungen des
Präsidenten des BBK entler bestätigt
unabhängig davon was dort diskutiert
wird ob ein Blackout oder ein brown-
groß angelegter Stromausfall oder
planmäßig in kleineren Bereichen wichtig
ist wir dürfen uns in Deutschland nicht
daran gewöhnen dass ein Stromausfall
größerer Art zu Normalität wird
in dieser Einschätzung unterscheiden wir
uns ganz deutlich unter anderem von der
regierenden Bürgermeisterin hier in
Berlin Franziska Giffey die sowas immer
mal wieder angedeutet hat ich glaube wir
müssen Vorsorge treffen dass solche
Stromausfälle nicht oder nur in ganz
geringen Umfang hier in diesem Land
stattfinden
leider Liebe Ampel Koalitionäre haben
sie nur zum Teil unseren Anträgen voll
geleistet können aber immerhin deswegen
springen Sie aus unserer Sicht zu kurz
meine Damen und Herren die Stärkung der
inneren Sicherheit der zivilen
Verteidigung des Bevölkerungsschutzes
und des Katastrophenschutzes das wissen
wir auch sind nicht umsonst aber die
Beträge sind leistbar diese Beträge
sollten es uns wert sein wenn nicht
jetzt wann dann wollen wir diese
Bereiche Stärken andere Bereiche haben
zurückzustehen zu den Anfängen von
Corona haben wir in den letzten
Koalitionen konjunkturmittel auch für
das BMI bereitgestellt um verschiedene
Bereiche zu stärken diese Mittel laufen
planmäßig aus gar keine Frage aber die
Begründung für die Aufstockung dieser
Mittel bleibt in Teilbereichen noch
bestehen geben Sie sich einen Ruck
stärken sie gerade jetzt viel deutlicher
das BBK das THW und die Bundespolizei
die Menschen in unserem Land würden es
Ihnen danken dann
dann hätten sie uns in diesem Bereichen
auch an ihrer Seite ich muss die Debatte
noch abwarten aber die Chance haben Sie
wahrscheinlich leider vertan deswegen
werden wir alle Voraussicht nach diesem
Etat nicht zustimmen können vielen Dank
fürs freundliche zuhören
so weit hier die Eröffnung zur Debatte
zum Einzelplan 6 und 21 zum inneren und
Heimatmuseum sowie zum
Datenschutzbeauftragten und auf die
Opposition folgt nun eine
Koalitionspartei in Person von Martin
Gerster SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen
Kollegen sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin
Nancy Feser es ist gerade mal sieben
Wochen Herde haben wir hier über den
Regierungsentwurf für den Haushalt 23
diskutiert was haben wir uns alles
anhören müssen von der
Opposition einerseits wurde von der
Union immer betont die Schuldenbremse
müssen unbedingt eingehalten werden
andererseits hieß es von allen Seiten
hier zu wenig da zu wenig und sowieso
ist alles ja ganz fürchterlich heute
steht fest trotz auslaufender
corona-konjunkturpakete was ja absehbar
und planmäßig war
13,1 Milliarden Euro stehen bereit für
innere Sicherheit
Integrationspolitik Digitalisierung
Sport und Bevölkerungsschutz das sind
1,8 Milliarden Euro mehr als in der
ursprüngliche Finanzplanung und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich finde das
ist ein sehr sehr gutes Ergebnis
die Hälfte die Hälfte des Etats für 23
ist für die Sicherheitsbehörden
vorgesehen dass Bundesinnenministerium
und die nachgeordneten Behörden erhalten
1607 zusätzliche Stellen schon im
Regierungsentwurf waren noch einmal
1.000 zusätzliche Stellen bei der
Bundespolizei vorgesehen zum Schutz der
Flug und Sehhilfen Grenzschutz und zu
Verstärkung der Schiffsbesatzung in
Nord- und Ostsee das ist richtige
notwendig und ich kann die Kritik von
Friedrich Merz und der Union ehrlich
gesagt am stellenaufwuchs überhaupt
nicht nachvollziehen denn das ist
wichtig dass wir hier was tun liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Sicherheit und Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende das war unser Ansatz bei der
Ampel bei den Beratungen und vielen
Gesprächen rund um den Haushalt und ich
möchte mich hier bei shamila Schäfer und
Thorsten lieb ganz ganz herzlich
bedanken für die sehr sehr gute
Zusammenarbeit allein in der
Bereinigungssitzung haben wir mit 58
Anträgen und 11 Maßgabe Beschlüssen viel
bewegt so dass wir heute guten Gewissens
sagen können die Innenpolitik ist eine
klare Gewinnerin der
Haushaltsverhandlungen bei der inneren
Sicherheit und bei der cyberabwehr
stellen wir zusätzlich 41 Millionen Euro
bereit seit Putins Angriff auf die
Ukraine hat sich beispielsweise ja auch
die Sicherheitslage im Ostseeraum massiv
verändert im Haushaltsausschuss haben
wir auf Initiative der Ampel 21
Millionen Euro zusätzlich mobilisiert
für kontroll- und Streifenboote aber
auch für mehrzweckbote darüber hinaus
vier Millionen Euro für die Beschaffung
von Drohnen zum Schutz von kritischer
Infrastruktur das Bundesamt für
Sicherheit der Informationstechnik kann
für eine Million Euro zusätzlich eine
Austauschplattform zu Cyberangriffen
aufbauen und erhält noch einmal 52
zusätzliche Stellen vor allem zur
Stärkung der IT-Sicherheit in unserem
Land liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
halten wir für absolut notwendig und ist
richtig investiertes Geld
mit dem Haushalt 23 stellen wir als Amt
für Koalition auf 75 Millionen Euro
bereit für ein bundesaufnahmeprogramm
Afghanistan wir unterlegen damit den
Plan der Bundesregierung monatlich etwa
1.000 Menschen mit Familien aus Afghan
mit Familien aus Afghanistan nach
Deutschland zu holen ein wichtiges
Signal dass wir Verantwortung übernehmen
für Afghanistan und die Menschen und
wenn ich über Menschen spreche dann will
ich sagen dass es uns auch ein großes
Anliegen war die
migrationsberatungsstellen für
Erwachsene Zuwanderer zu stärken und
nicht zu schwächen plus 24 Millionen
Euro an dieser Stelle ist richtig gut
damit auch die Beschäftigten
Planungssicherheit bekommen und die
Integrationskurse auch hier gibt es ein
Plus von 153 Millionen Euro und das ist
glaube ich auch sehr gut nur auch mit
entsprechenden Mitteln kann der hohe
Bedarf beispielsweise an Sprachkursen im
nächsten Jahr gedeckt werden liebe
Kolleginnen ich freue mich auch sehr
dass wir mit unserem Beschlüssen zum
Haushalt 23 die Investitionen in den
zivil und Katastrophenschutz auf sehr
hohem Niveau fortführen 104 Millionen
Euro haben wir in der Ampel zusätzlich
für BBK und THW mobilisiert das THW
beispielsweise profitiert davon enorm
die sb-mitte bleiben auf Rekordniveau +
12,5 Millionen Euro die aus- und
Fortbildung wird deutlich gestärkt auch
die THW-Jugend ich glaube das ist das
richtige Signal in die Familie des THW
und an dieser Stelle möchte ich auch mal
allen Einsatzkräften ganz herzlich
danken egal ob Haupt-
beim BBK lieber André bergke da machen
wir ja auch noch viel da haben wir noch
mal viel bewegt auch in der
Bereinigungssitzung plus 5 Millionen
Euro für sellbroadcast und eins sind
Sirenen und Förderprogramm in Höhe von
30 Millionen Euro aber ich finde das ist
auch gut ist dass wir die Länder jetzt
zwingen sich finanziell entsprechend
daran beteiligen denn ich habe ehrlich
gesagt die Schnauze ein bisschen voll
dass wir im Bund bezahlen für Aufgaben
die die Länder eigentlich übernehmen
sollten und dann kriegen wir als
Dankeschön noch harsche Kritik
beispielsweise aus Düsseldorf vor der
Stuttgart das kann so nicht bleiben und
deswegen haben wir entsprechende
vorgesehen
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen für
die Ampel für uns gehört zur inneren
Sicherheit auch das Thema wirksame
Prävention und politische Bildung ich
freue mich wirklich sehr dass wir die
Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung
noch mal deutlich stärken konnten mit
+12,4 Millionen Euro und 21 stellen das
ist gut für die Bekämpfung von
Rechtsextremismus und Rassismus das ist
auch gut um beispielsweise
Desinformationskampagnen besser
entlarven zu können und ich freue mich
im übrigen auch sehr dass wir es
geschafft haben Initiativen zur Stärkung
des jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland und
den Kampf gegen Antisemitismus noch
einmal mit plus 21 Millionen Euro zu
stärken
Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende dafür
steht auch bekanntermaßen der Sport gut
dass das restart-förderprogramm für den
breiten Sport das auf Initiative von
Nancy Feser der Bund in diesem und im
nächsten Jahr mit insgesamt 25 Millionen
Euro finanziert jetzt startet und weil
es nach pandem nach der Pandemie auf
vieles aufzuholen gilt beim Sport haben
wir weit über den Zuständigkeitsbereich
des Bundes den Sport noch mals deutlich
gestärkt iat in Leipzig plus eineinhalb
Millionen Euro Behindertensport plus
1,25 Millionen Euro campussport
Deutschland in Frankfurt plus 400.000
Euro Altenberg Sanierung der
Rennschlitten und Bobbahn plus 1,75
Millionen Euro und zu guter letzt
natürlich die Finanzierung einer
weiteren Scheibe des sehr erfolgreichen
kommunalen Sportstätten
Sanierungsprogramms in Höhe von 400
Millionen Euro ein sehr sehr gut
angelegtes wie ich finde bin gleiches
natürlich über einen anderen Einzelplan
Haushalt tierisch dargestellt wird
zusammenfassend will ich sagen es ist
uns gelungen dass das
Bundesinnenministerium und die
nachgeordneten Behörden mit unseren
Beschluss im Haushaltsausschuss gut
aufgestellt sind für die großen
Herausforderungen und ich wünsche der
Bundesregierung und von herzenden
Ministerin Nancy Faeser mit ihrem Team
und dem Behörden viel Erfolg bei der
Umsetzung des etas 23 herzlichen Dank
eine kleine Anmerkung Kollege Gerste
ehrlich oder nicht ehrlich
parlamentarischer Ausdrucksweise geht
anders
das Wort hat der Abgeordnete Markus Bühl
für die afd-fraktion
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die Statistik des Bundesamtes für
Migration und Flüchtlinge kurz BAMF
weist bei den Erstanträgen auf Asyl mit
fast 24.000 Anträgen alleine im Oktober
2022 einen Anstieg um 80% im Vergleich
zum Vorjahresmonat auf wir reden dabei
vom höchsten Monatswert seit Ende 2016
das Szenario wie im Katastrophenjahr
2015 wiederholt sich sehenden Auges und
was macht die Bundesregierung statt sich
endlich um einen umfassenden Grenzschutz
zu kümmern und den großen sozialmagneten
abzuschalten genau das Gegenteil
erhebliche Teile des Haushalts so auch
im Bereich der Innenpolitik verwendet
links grün für ideologieprojekte zum
Beispiel zu Unterhaltung der
asylindustrie wie man einen Titeln wie
der Behörden unabhängigen asylberatung
sehen kann bei der Ausrüstung zu unserer
inneren Sicherheit kreist dagegen der
Rotstift die Sicherheitslage droht noch
weiter abzurutschen
der vorgelegte Haushalt des
Innenministeriums ist das erschütternde
Zahlenwerk dieser linksgrünen
Bundesregierung und ihrer Ideologie
getriebenen Innenpolitik die wir
ablehnen
kommen wir zu einigen Einzelheiten es
soll zwar tausend zusätzliche Stellen
bei der Bundespolizei geben was
allerdings hauptsächlich die
altersabgänge kompensiert zumal auch
erstmal drei Jahre ausgebildet werden
muss für die Jungen polizeiabsolventen
haben wir die Einführung von
ortszuschlägen für Ballungsgebiete mit
hohen Mieten gefordert was von allen
anderen Fraktionen abgelehnt wurde 15
Prozent der Einsatzfahrzeuge der
Bundespolizei haben eine
Kilometerlaufleistung jenseits der
200.000 km die logische Folge wäre
diesen Haushaltstitel zur
Fahrzeugbeschaffung wie von uns
gefordert zu erhöhen aber nicht mit
Links gelb die Koalition hat den Titel
Fahrzeuge für die Bundespolizei weiter
gekürzt
Steuergeld für links grüne
ideologieprojekte wird allerdings
reichlich aufgeblendet so zum Beispiel
für die
üppig versorgte asylindustrie neu für
nächstes Jahr ist mit 20 Millionen Euro
eine behördenunabhängige
asylverfahrensberatung damit wird neben
der Beratung durch das BAMF eine
Doppelstruktur mit Steuergeldern
aufgebaut was soll denn einer derartigen
Beratungen beraten werden was das Banf
nicht kann und wenn eine Beratung
Behörden unabhängig ist wozu bedarf es
staatlicher Fördergelder eine weitere
Absurdität ist die Förderung der
freiwilligen Ausreise es werden Personen
die zur Ausreise rechtlich verpflichtet
sind mit Prämien ausgestattet wenn sie
sich rechtskonform verhalten wie wenig
Willens diese Links gelbe
Bundesregierung ist geltendes Recht mit
den völlig normalen Mitteln eines
Rechtsstaates durchzusetzen zeigt dieses
Beispiel sehr eindrücklich
auch hier wird stattdessen Steuergeld in
Größenordnungen verschwendet
ausreisepflichtige und abgelehnte
Asylbewerber müssen konsequent und zügig
abgeschoben werden statt ihnen Geld für
die Ausreise anzubieten die Links gelb
grüne Regierung setzt unverdrossen ihre
Politik der sperrangelweit offenen
Grenzen bei eingeschaltetem
sozialmagneten fort und das bei den
bereits existierenden Zuständen wir
halten dagegen und werden diesen
Haushalt ablehnen denn wir sagen unser
Land zuerst vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
Markus Bühl war das von der afd-fraktion
eigentlich würde der Innenausschuss auch
unter Vorsitz eines AFD Abgeordneten
Tagen allerdings konnten sich dort die
Abgeordneten bislang noch nicht
durchringen den entsprechenden
Kandidaten zu wählen so dass es bislang
noch keinen Vorsitz im Innenausschuss
gibt
Frau Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ja wir
hatten eingelage es gibt riesige über
Jahrzehnte gewachsene Investitionsstaus
gerade im Bereich des Zivilschutzes und
der Cyber Security und nicht zuletzt die
Flut im Ahrtal und der gescheiterte
warentag 2020 haben die Verletzlichkeit
des Bevölkerungsschutzes in Deutschland
deutlich zu Tage getreten lassen neben
der Klimakrise macht auch der russische
Angriffskrieg mitten in Europa die
sicherheitspolitischen Aufgabe auch
hierzuladen und nicht kleiner sondern
größer
doch leider konnten wir mit dem
Sondervermögen nur die Grundlage
schaffen die Fähigkeitslücken bei der
Bundeswehr nicht aber beim
Bevölkerungsschutz oder bei der
cybersicherheit zu schließen denn die
Union wollte ja Zivilschutz und
cybersicherheit die er genauso für
unsere Sicherheit relevant sind und
übrigens auch noch mal jenseits der
konventionellen Kriegsführung auf gar
keinen Fall in dem Sondervermögen
abbilden und darum ist es auch
unglaubwürdig dass die Union erst ein
investitionsstoff verursacht dann ein
beherztes anpacken dieses Investitions
verhindert und sich jetzt beschwert das
zu wenig Geld da ist
ja genau sie sagen jetzt finanziell wie
es aus dem aktuellen Haushalt und das
machen wir ja auch so gut es geht im
Rahmen der Schuldenbremse deswegen
stärken wir zum Beispiel das THW das BBK
allein in der Bereinigungssitzung mit
rund 80 Millionen Euro zusätzlich wir
fördern damit dass Ehrenamt
Ausbildungsmaßnahmen den Selbstschutz
der Bevölkerung
und wir investieren auch in die Warnung
der Bevölkerung und legen das Sirenen
Förderprogramm neu auf und wir machen
auch den Weg frei für die Anschaffung
von großen Löschfahrzeugen und sorgen
dafür dass die Luftrettung für den
Zivilschutz in Zukunft noch deutlich
verbessert wird durch einen
maßgabebeschluss und das ist angesichts
der größer werdenden Gefahr durch für
Waldbrände und Flutkatastrophen durch
die Klimakrise auch sehr wichtig aber
der Unterschied zu ihren Anträgen ist
immer wir haben das machbar und seriös
gegenfinanziert denn sie kürzen bei
it oder Integrationsmaßnahmen beides
Bereiche die schon jetzt total auf Kante
genäht sind und die für die innere
Sicherheit entscheidend sind und ihre
heutigen Anträge im Umfang von 140
Millionen Euro die sind gar nicht gegen
finanziert und sich jetzt hinzustellen
und zu sagen das Geld reicht nicht das
kann ja jeder aber man sollte sich das
nicht
wenn man als seriöse Oppositionspartei
durchgehen will
froh dass es uns trotz aller
Schwierigkeiten gelungen ist bei
cybersicherheit auch noch mehr zu tun
wir ermöglichen jetzt den Aufbau einer
Plattform die schnellstmöglich
Erkenntnisse über Cyberattacken und auch
das Lösen dieser Probleme stellverteilt
so dass eben Lösungen auch schnell
gefunden werden können und auch beim
Schutz von kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen gehen wir voran gerade im
Bereich der kritischen Infrastruktur
werden jetzt Lösungen erarbeitet damit
sich eben auch Investitionen in die
cybersicherheit dort lohnen und statt
bei Integration zu kürzen so wie die
Union das ja vorgeschlagen hat bauen wir
die Integrationskurse mit 153 Millionen
Euro aus und das ist ehrlicherweise auch
dringend notwendig denn wir müssen jetzt
zum einen damit dafür sorgen dass wir
mit Migration gut umgehen weil es die
einfach in einer krisengebeutelten
weltperspektive geben wird und zum
Anderen sind auch Integrationskurse ein
total wichtiger Baustein um angesichts
des demografischen Wandels aber auch als
Fachkräftemangels diesen abzubauen und
auch das das möchte ich so klar sagen
das sind sicherheitsrelevante
Investitionen denn wir haben einen ganz
großen Bedarf an Handwerkerinnen und
anderen Fachkräften um den Weg in einen
krisenfesten Wohlstand zu schaffen etwa
mit einer resilienten Energieversorgung
und einer starken klimaneutralen
Industrie
und mit diesem Haushalt tragen wir eben
auch dazu bei auch im innenpolitischen
Etat und deswegen möchte ich mich dafür
auch noch mal ganz herzlich bedanken bei
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Ausschuss insbesondere bei Martin
Gerster und Thorsten lieb und natürlich
auch bei Nancy fazer und ihrem Haus für
die konstruktive Zusammenarbeit und auch
die Unterstützung unserer Arbeit vielen
herzlichen Dank
Jamila Schäfer war das hier für Bündnis
90 die Grünen sie ist Vorsitzende des
bundesfinanzierungsgremiums das ist das
Gremium das vom Bundesfinanzministerium
über das bundesschuldwesen informiert
werden muss dort sind sitzen auch
Haushälter drin
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion
würde es nur um die Zahlen im Haushalt
gehen dann müsste man nüchtern
feststellen wo man auch hinzieht überall
massive Personalaufstockung
und das obwohl bis heute der
Stellenzuwachs aus dem letzten Haushalt
nicht annähernd besetzt ist eine Zahl es
gibt allein 9000 offene Stellen bei der
Bundespolizei
also zurück zur Politik der Haushalt
sollte ausdruckpolitischer Schwerpunkte
sein reden wir darüber die
Innenministerin hat die letzten Wochen
eine Reihe von Texten Papieren
veröffentlicht zur Bekämpfung der
organisierten Kriminalität die
Ankündigung einer nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie und Beiträge zur
Sicherheit
informationstechnischer Systeme wie
sieht eigentlich die Realität aus
die Integrität der Informationstechnik
wird nicht mit einer Behörde geschützt
deren Spitze gerade nicht resilient
gegenüber fremden Interessen war ich
meine das BSI
das leitungsproblem und die Vorwürfe
sind schon sehr lange bekannt reagiert
wurde offenbar erst als der Hashtag
cyberclown trendete ich meine die lange
Tatenlosigkeit in BMI ist das
eigentliche Problem
[Applaus]
rechte Gewalt wird nicht dadurch
bekämpft indem man den massiven Anstieg
rechter und rassistischer Straftaten
einfach um etikettiert der Aufwuchs von
Straftaten die
vorgeblich politisch nicht zuzuordnen
sind beläuft sich im Vergleich von 2019
6.600 zu in
2021.300 wir wissen alle was ich
dahinter verbirgt Angriffe durch
reichsburger Selbstverwalter
antisemitische verschwörungsgläubige und
Tag X Fanatiker sowas gehört für mich in
die politisch motivierte Kriminalität
rechts hier muss etwas passieren
und verloren gegangenes Vertrauen in die
Polizei wird nicht wieder hergestellt
wenn rassistische Polizeigewalt wie auch
zuletzt selbst durch die Ministerin
geleugnet wird wir warten auf den
unabhängigen polizeibeauftragten und die
Kennzeichnungspflicht keine Eckpunkte zu
einem zukünftigen Gesetz bisher von den
Ministerium und zuletzt
das Archiv über den Rechtsterrorismus
ich sage es bleibt so lange ein leeres
Versprechen bis nicht endlich die Akten
des Verfassungsschutzes zum Oktoberfest
Attentat freigegeben
42 Jahre ist dieser Anschlag jetzt her
Frau Innenministerin sie haben selbst in
Hessen mit einer Petition gegen die
Geheimhaltung der nsu-akten gekämpft
machen sie den BFV endlich eine Ansage
Aufklärung zur Kontinuität des Rechts
heraus und der Rolle des Staates gelingt
nur wenn endlich die Akten freigegeben
werden vielen Dank
Martina Renner war das für die
Linksfraktion die innenpolitische
Sprecherin auf sie folgten und Thorsten
lieb er ist der stellvertretende
Vorsitzende des Rechtsausschusses und
Mitglied der Liberalen im Deutschen
Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin im Einzelplan des
Bundesministeriums des Innern und für
Heimat bilden sich die großen
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit in
besonderer Weise ab ob es um innere
Sicherheit Bevölkerungs und
Katastrophenschutz Fragen des
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalts und der
Integration gerade getrieben durch den
heute 9 Monate andauernden
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine und nicht zuletzt den Sport
all das kombiniert sich im Einzelplan 06
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
insgesamt 80 Anträge und
maßgabebeschlüsse haben wir als
fortschrittskoalition im Rahmen der
einzelplanberatung der
Bereinigungssitzung gestellt das zeugt
von der Handlungsfähigkeit dieser
Koalition gerade in dieser volatilen
Zeit bei Themen der Innenpolitik liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
man kann allerdings in dieser Woche
nicht über den Etat dieses Ministeriums
sprechen ohne nicht zumindest kurz auf
die laufende Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
einzugehen ich nutze die Gelegenheit in
Frau Ministerin ganz herzlich Dank zu
sagen für das starke Signal gestern und
natürlich in gleicher Weise auch der
Mannschaft vielen Dank dafür da
notwendig
wenn ich allerdings sehe wie die
iranische Fußballnationalmannschaft bei
ihren ersten WM-Spiel ihre Unterstützung
ausgedrückt hat für die vielen Frauen in
diesem Land die unter erheblichen
persönlichen Risiko mit dem Slogan
Frauen Leben Freiheit sich für mehr
Freiheit und Menschlichkeit einsetzen
und das liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
verdient unsere nachhaltige
Unterstützung in diesem Haus
dann muss ich sagen dann wundere ich
mich schon sehr warum die
traditionsbewussten und selbstbewussten
Fußballverbände in Europa so schnell
einklicken und nicht ein bisschen Mut
wenigstens aufbringen in dieser
schwierigen Fragen und der
Vorbildfunktion die der Sport immer für
sich in Anspruch nimmt an dieser Stelle
Genüge zu tun deswegen sind die Verbände
aufgefordert zukünftig nachhaltig dafür
zu sorgen dass solche Vergabe nicht mehr
stattfinden können liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
dafür braucht es aber eben noch
demokratische Länder die bereit sind
genau solche sportgroße Ereignisse
durchzuführen durchzusetzen und sich
dafür zu engagieren liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen das setzt voraus moderne
Sportanlagen moderne Trainingsstätten
und da haben wir der Kollege Gerster hat
das gerade schon wundervoll das will ich
nämlich gar nicht wiederholen ausgeführt
an ganz vielen Stellen viel getan damit
Spitzensport und Leistungssport in
diesem Land nicht nur würdige Training
sondern auch würdige Sportstätten findet
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mir persönlich besonders wichtig dass
mag ich an der Stelle noch mal
anzusprechen ist die Förderung des
parasports sind das auch ein wichtiger
Beitrag zur Inklusion in diesem Land das
sollte die entsprechend auch
weiterwürdigen und wir haben auch das
ist schon angesprochen worden im Bereich
des Bevölkerungsschutzes in der
Katastrophenhilfe vielen Bereichen der
inneren Sicherheit massiv noch mal
investiert gerade in der
Bereinigungssitzung insofern sage ich
Herr Kollege hat sich das heute positiv
abgehoben von der Debatte die wir
phasenweise geführt worden oder Ampel
vorgeworfen ist wir würden Abbau im
Bereich der inneren Sicherheit betreiben
oder sagen gar in Sicherheitsrisiko ich
hoffe die Debatte bleibt so denn wir
haben eine ganze Menge an dieser Stelle
investiert das ein gutes Signal für die
innere Sicherheit in diesem Land
abschließend möchte ich noch ein anderes
sehr ernstes Thema ansprechen die
Schüsse auf ein Nebengebäude der Alten
Synagoge in Essen haben sicherlich nicht
nur mich sondern viele in diesem Land
betroffen gemacht immer wieder müssen
wir leider erleben wie Antisemitismus
scheinbar Konjunktur bekommt in
Krisenzeiten deswegen sage ich nochmals
an dieser Stelle solange irgendeine
jüdische Einrichtung in diesem Land
unter Polizeischutz stehen muss solange
sind wir als Politik aufgefordert alles
dafür zu tun dass Antisemitismus in
diesem Land nachhaltig bekämpft wird
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deswegen ist mir eine Freude das auch an
dieser Stelle es gelungen ist eine ganze
Reihe von Projekten in diesem Haushalt
auch unterzubringen trotz in dieser
schwierigen Lage auch das zeigt von
Handlungsfähigkeit abschließend auch vor
meiner Seite ganz herzlichen Dank an die
berichterstatte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Martin Gaster chanela Schäfer und auch
an den Kollegen berghäcker mit dem man
wirklich seriös das ganze verhandelt
konnte und danke auch an das Haus ich
denke damit ist eine gute Grundlage
geschaffen für eine gute Arbeit in diese
Ministerium im kommenden Jahr vielen
herzlichen Dank
ein Dank von der FDP hier in Richtung
bundesinnenministerin der Tonfall dürfte
sich ändern mit Andrea Lindholz der
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Haushalt
für das Jahr 2023 ist auch eine Bilanz
für das erste Amtsjahr der
bundesinnenministerin sie Frau Feser
haben vieles angekündigt aber weniges
ist in dieser Zeit passiert
im Sommer
diesen Jahres kündigten sie zum Beispiel
einen Neustart im Bevölkerungsschutz an
in diesem Haushalt ist davon allerdings
nichts zu sehen die Vorgängerregierung
hatte als Reaktion auf die
corona-pandemie ab dem Jahr 2020 eine
halbe Milliarde Euro zusätzlich in das
THW und hunderte Millionen in das BBK
investiert und im März 2021 hatten wir
die Neuausrichtung des BWK das neue
Kompetenzzentrum von Bund und Ländern
ein sirenenprogramm die Warnung per SMS
den sogenannten cell broadcast und
vieles mehr auf den Weg gebracht das war
der Neustart im Bevölkerungsschutz den
sie den die Ampel mit diesem Haushalt
jetzt abwirkt
unter dem Strich sinken die Ausgaben für
das THW und das BWK im kommenden Jahr um
190 Millionen Euro die Kürzungen wären
sogar noch größer gewesen wenn ich der
Haushaltsausschuss mit einigen guten
Beschlüssen und dafür bin ich auch sehr
dankbar gegengesteuert hätte aber in die
zivile Verteidigung liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen investieren Sie keinen
einzigen Cent und das obwohl Krieg in
Europa herrscht das ist alles andere als
ein Neustart das ist eine
haushaltspolitische Vollbremsung
angesichts von Corona Flut und Krieg
muss hier viel mehr passieren die
Sicherheitslage hat sich 2000 seit 2019
fundamental verändert es reicht deshalb
auch nicht auf den Haushalt von 20 19 zu
verweisen fakt ist dass der
Bundeshaushalt des Innenministeriums um
1,8 Milliarden Euro zum Vorjahr sich
reduziert und dass das in dieser
Situation nicht akzeptabel ist
die Union hat mehr als 400 Millionen
Euro zusätzlich für den zivil und
Katastrophenschutz beantragt weil es zum
Beispiel wesentlich mehr Vorsorge für
Stromausfälle braucht das haben wir von
bbk-präsident Thiesler erst in diesen
Tagen gehört und natürlich liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen und
müssen sich solche Mittel auch aus dem
regulären Haushalt finanzieren man muss
eben die richtigen Prioritäten setzen
die bundesinnenministerin hat auch eine
neue europäische Flüchtlingspolitik
angekündigt aber die irreguläre
Migration nach Deutschland steigt massiv
an wir haben in diesem Jahr schon
160.000 Asylbewerber in diesem Bereich
zusätzlich zu den rund 1,1 Millionen
schutzbedürftigen Kriegsflüchtlingen aus
der Ukraine und die Tendenzen bei der
irregulären Migration sind stark
steigend wir befinden uns als also in
einer massiven migrationskrise und Sie
liebe Frau Innenministerin brauchen
Wochen um beispielsweise auf die
illegale Migration aus der Schweiz aus
Tschechien oder auch auf die visa-
die Kommunen
die Kommunen und Länder sind längst am
Limit wir konnten das gestern lesen es
hat sich zum einen die Justizministerin
Baden-Württembergs Frau Gentges an Sie
gewandt und zum anderen hat der
Vizepräsident des Städtetages gestern
geäußert wir werden das aus eigener
Kraft nicht schaffen an dem sogenannten
flüchtlingsgipfel den nicht nur ein
flüchtlingsgipfelchen nenne im Oktober
hat man unter anderem als Lösung weitere
56 zusätzliche bundesimmobilien mit
Platz für 4000 Personen zur Verfügung
gestellt das gut aber das reicht nicht
denn allein im Oktober hatten wir 24.000
Asylanträge und bereits wenige Tage nach
dem Treffen mit den Ländern die ja um
Entlastung gebeten haben wurde das neue
Aufnahmeprogramm der Ampel für
Afghanistan den Ländern vorgestellt sie
wurden vor vollendete Tatsachen gestellt
und ich frag mich allen Ernstes welche
Ignoranz besitzen sie eigentlich
gegenüber denjenigen die das alles vor
Ort stemmen müssen
angesichts des Krieges in der Ukraine
ist es gut dass die Hilfsbereitschaft in
unserem Land anhaltend hoch ist aber
auch hier müssen wir mehr tun es ist
möglich dass noch mehr Menschen aus der
Ukraine fliehen weil sie im Winter ohne
Strom ohne Wärme und ohne Wasser
auskommen müssen Deutschland hat zehnmal
so viele Flüchtlinge aufgenommen aus
diesem Bereich wie Frankreich und es
muss mehr getan werden wir brauchen ein
europäisches Verteilersystem und ihre
Aktivitäten an dieser Stelle sind gleich
null es gibt bis dato kein
Verteilungssystem und die Vorbereitungen
in Deutschland werden auch nicht
ausreichen das zeigen uns auch die
Stellungnahmen der Länder
bezeichnend ist an dieser Stelle
im übrigen auch dass der Bundeskanzler
gestern in seiner Rede die größte
migrationskrise seit Bestehen der
Republik mit keinem Wort erwähnt ich
will nur eines sagen man kann versuchen
Dinge tot zu schweigen oder nicht zu
nennen aber das wird am Ende nicht
funktionieren
sie haben einen
Plan und Kampf gegen Rechtsextremismus
angekündigt gleich zu Beginn im letzten
Jahr auf die Umsetzung des Aktionsplanes
warten wir noch heute und es ist gut
dass unsere Maßnahmen aus der letzten
Legislaturperiode offensichtlich wirken
denn aktuelle Studien aus Leipzig zeigen
dass harte rechtsextreme Einstellungen
seit einiger Zeit schon abnehmen ich
würde mir aber wünschen dass an dieser
Stelle noch mehr passiert nicht nur
Rechtsextremisten auch Corona die Flut
der Krieg der schutzkritische
Infrastrukturen klimakleber und
Migration fordern unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden anstatt sie weiter
zu stärken ruht sich die Ampel auf den
Aufwachsen der Vergangenheit aus aus dem
was wir über die letzten Jahre
sukzessive jedes Jahr an Mitteln und
Möglichkeiten zur Verfügung gestellt
haben und gerade
die von ihnen großartig angekündigte
ruhegehaltsfähigkeit der Polizei Zulage
für die ich sie auch ausdrücklich gelobt
habe und die ich ganz hervorragend finde
ist seit zwölf Monaten Liebe
ampelkollegen immer noch nicht umgesetzt
ich finde unsere Polizistinnen und
Polizisten können zu Recht erwarten dass
sie Wort halten
sie haben jetzt die Eckpunkte für das
kritis-dachgesetz vorgestellt finde ich
gut das ist ein richtiger ein wichtiger
Schritt aber ich hoffe dass diesen
Eckpunkten jetzt in schnellen Schritten
auch mehr folgt
lassen sie bevor ich zum Schluss komme
mich noch eine Frage stellen vielleicht
Frau Innenminister können Sie heute
etwas zur Aufhellung einer Frage aus dem
Haushaltsberatungen dazustellungen
nehmen dazu Stellung nehmen es steht
nämlich die Frage im Raum ob sie und die
Ampel die Stelle des Präsidenten der
Bundesakademie für die öffentliche
Verwaltung deshalb von B6 auf B8
hochgruppiert haben um die Versetzung
von bsi-chef schönbogen vorzubereiten es
geht hier immerhin um einen Betrag von
1.100 Euro pro Monat vielleicht auch
noch ein bisschen mehr aber vielleicht
könnte man zu dem Vorgang hier heute
etwas sagen
alles in allem
empfinden wir den Haushalt für
enttäuschend die Bilanz nach dem ersten
Amts ja ebenfalls ein sinkende Haushalt
im Innenministerium in diesen Zeiten ist
kein gutes Zeichen es wird den
sicherheitspolitischen Herausforderungen
nicht gerecht und wir werden ihn daher
auch ablehnen
während der Rede von Andrea Lindholz hat
die bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser
schon ab und an mit dem Kopf geschüttelt
und sie könnte jetzt noch einmal
erläutern warum sie da so
sich so gezeigt hatten sie es hier die
nächste Rednerin in der Debatte
Dankeschön herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren meiner sehr
verehrten Abgeordneten wissen Sie Frau
Abgeordnete Lindholz ich finde sie
bringen hier ziemlich viel
Selbstbewusstsein auf dafür dass sie 16
Jahre lang an der Spitze des
Innenministeriums für den zivil und
Katastrophenschutz herzlich wenig getan
haben
und ich habe einen sehr ernstzunehmenden
Punkt anzumerken Frau Abgeordnete
Lindholz den ich nicht in Ordnung finde
sie sollten wirklich nicht mehr von
größter migrationskrise reden aus von
dieser Stelle meine Damen und Herren wir
haben keine große migrationskrise
sie sehen schon von wem sie den meisten
Beifall dafür bekommen weil sie machen
nichts anderes mit dieser Bemerkung als
die Gesellschaft zu spalten und die AFD
zu stärken nichts anderes machen Sie
hier nichts anderes
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine Damen
und Herren für Sicherheit zu sorgen das
ist in dieser schwierigen Zeit die
zentrale Priorität dieser
Bundesregierung das gilt für die
Sicherheit nach außen nach innen aber
insbesondere auch für die soziale
Sicherheit die elementare Voraussetzung
für die innere Sicherheit ist und
deswegen danke ich auch mal allen
Beteiligten für die Einigung beim
Bürgergeld weil das so wichtig auch für
die innere Sicherheit ist
und es geht um den Schutz unserer
Demokratie mit dem Angriff auf die
Ukraine hat sich auch die Bedrohungslage
in Deutschland massiv verschärft und
darauf reagieren wir entschlossen auf
allen Ebenen unsere Sicherheitsbehörden
haben alle
schutzmassivmaßnahmen massiv
hochgefahren wir sind wachsam und wir
sind vorbereitet und mit dem Haushalt
2023 stärken wir die inneren Sicherheit
in Deutschland weiter meine Damen und
Herren und dafür sind folgende
Grundsätze für mich sehr zentral wir
verteidigen unsere freiheitliche
Demokratie unseren Rechtsstaat wir
machen Staat und Gesellschaft
widerstandsfähiger und wir sorgen für
ein neues Sicherheitsbewusstsein in
unserem Land
die erste und oberste Priorität für mich
ist der Schutz unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen Gesellschaft und damit
ist nicht nur Schutz jedes einzelnen
gemeint ist geht es ums ganze um die Art
und Weise wie wir hier leben meine Damen
und Herren und darum darf ich den
Haushaltspolitikern insbesondere der
Koalition Frau Schäfer Herr lieb und
Herrn Gerster auch noch mal ganz
herzlich insbesondere für die
Aufstockung der Mittel in der Bekämpfung
gegen Antisemitismus danken weil das
eine der größten Aufgaben für uns ist
diejenigen die unsere innere Sicherheit
bedrohen Terroristen Extremisten auch
staatliche Akteure wollen unsere
Gesellschaft spalten sie wollen uns
schwach und unsere Demokratie instabil
erscheinen lassen sie wollen elementare
Bereiche unserer Daseinsvorsorge stören
sie wollen das Vertrauen in unseren
Staat erschüttern und sie wollen
letztlich die Menschen in Angst
versetzen dass meine Damen und Herren
lassen wir nicht zu
wir halten dagegen indem wir gezielt
gegen Desinformationskampagnen vorgehen
und dafür sorgen dass sie nicht auf
fruchtbaren Boden fallen indem wir
Extremismus entschlossen bekämpfen und
dafür sorgen dass Hass und Hetze nicht
sich ausbreiten können und wir halten
dagegen indem wir unser Engagement für
Demokratie und Vielfalt in mit unserem
Demokratie fördergesetz massiv fördern
meine Damen und Herren auch dafür mein
Dank an die Koalition
denn Sicherheit für alle Menschen egal
wie viel Geld sie haben wen sie lieben
oder wo ihre familienhärmer herkamen das
gibt es nur in einer starken Demokratie
zweitens geht es mir darum in unserem
Land mehr Widerstandskraft zu geben das
gilt insbesondere für unsere Sicherheit
im cyberraum und für den Schutz unserer
Bevölkerung denn die Anzahl und auch die
Komplexität der Krisen mit denen wir
gleichzeitig konfrontiert sind hat in
den letzten Jahren drastisch zugenommen
Pandemie Extremwetter die Auswirkungen
des Ukraine Krieges oder die Angriffe
auf die kritische Infrastruktur sind
ganz reale Bedrohung und gegen diese
Bedrohung Wappen wir uns wir stärken den
bevölkerungs- und Katastrophenschutz mit
noch einmal rund 225 Millionen Euro mit
insgesamt 640 Millionen Euro wir
modernisieren unser Warnsystem und bauen
die betreuungsreserve des Bundes weiter
aus wir stärk die logistischen
Fähigkeiten des THWs und wir investieren
in Ehrenamt
zivilschutzausbildung und
Digitalisierung des Bevölkerungsschutzes
die Herausforderung in diesem Bereich
sind enorm und weil wir die großen
Versäumnisse der letzten Jahre und
Jahrzehnte aufholen müssen aber wir
nehmen diese Herausforderung an diese
Koalition macht das Land
widerstandsfähiger
besonders im cyberraum hat sich die
Gefährdungslage durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine enorm erhöht deshalb ist es gut
dass wir auch in diesem Bereich einen
deutlichen aufwuchs gegenüber der
ursprünglichen Finanzplanung haben
dieses Geld nehmen wir in die Hand um
die Netze des Bundes zu härten um zivile
Infrastrukturen besser zu schützen und
um die Informationssicherheit in der
Bundesverwaltung zu stärken denn je
digitaler unsere Gesellschaft wird desto
mehr Schaden kann durch
Cyber-Sicherheit in Deutschland meine
Damen und Herren
was mir besonders wichtig ist im
Haushalt 2023 entfällt mehr als die
Hälfte des Budgets für den
Sicherheitsbereich der Einzelplan des
BMI sieht allein dafür rund 6,5
Milliarden Euro vor noch einmal 200
Millionen Euro mehr als in der
bisherigen Finanzplanung vorgesehen
außerdem werden insgesamt
1600 neue Stellen geschaffen deswegen
dafür auch noch mal mein herzliches
Dankeschön BBK und das THW bekommen 187
neue Stellen BKA und Bundespolizei
bekommen zusammen
1.188 neue Stellen und Frau Renner wir
stärken deshalb weil es notwendig ist
und die offenen Stellen bei der
Bundespolizei kommen daher dass wir eine
Menge
bundespolizeianwärterinnen Anwärter
haben die brauchen aber dann auch eine
anschlussverwendung ein eine Stelle in
der Bundespolizei deshalb sind die offen
und nicht weil die nicht besetzt sind
meine Damen und Herren
diese Arbeit der Polizistinnen und
Polizisten in diesem schwierigen Zeiten
die möchte ich nochmal hervorheben meine
Damen und Herren sie halten jeden Tag
für uns auf der Straße ihren Kopf hin
und deswegen gilt ihn auch mein
besonderer Dank bei der Organisation der
inneren Sicherheit in unserem Land
vielen Dank dafür
viel zu lang sind wir in diesem Jahr
davon in diesem Land davon ausgegangen
dass schon alles irgendwie gut gehen
wird es ist gut dass ich das geändert
hat dass wir hier einen echten
Bewusstseinswandel haben denn ich bin
überzeugt Sicherheit gibt es nicht zum
Nulltarif während der parlamentarischen
Beratung hat der Haushaltsausschuss den
Sicherheitsbereich noch weiter gestärkt
aber auch die Bereiche die für unseren
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
besonders wichtig sind beispielsweise
den Sport für den wir dieses Jahr das
restart-programm schon erreicht haben
jetzt damit Staaten ab dem 13 Dezember
es wird mit einem Mitteleinsatz von über
300 Millionen wird der Sportbereich
weiter gestärkt und ich möchte noch mal
besonders das Programm Integration durch
Sport hervorheben weil es ein wichtiger
Beitrag für den Zusammenhalt in unserer
Gesellschaft ist und auch die
spitzensportreform die sie ja diese
Woche gemeinsam mit dem DFB auf dem Weg
gebracht haben sind wichtige Bausteine
für die Stärkung des Sportes in unserem
Land meine Damen und Herren auch dafür
herzlichen Dank
und ich darf mich bei den
Haushaltspolitikern nochmal für die
Unterstützung bei dem so wichtigen
Bereich der Integration bedanken das ist
das Herangehen wenn wir viele
geflüchtete haben in unserem Land durch
den furchtbaren angriffskriegs in der
Ukraine und auch durch andere Kriege und
Krisenherde in der Welt darauf mit
Integration zu antworten und für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt zu
arbeiten dafür mein herzliches
Dankeschön und auch meinen Dank für das
bundesaufnahmeprogramm Afghanistan wir
helfen den Menschen weiter wir stehen zu
unseren Versprechungen und helfen den
Menschen in unserem Land
ganz lieben Dank an die konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit bei Jamila Schäfer bei dr
Thorsten lieb bei Martin Gerster aber
auch bei den Oppositionspolitikern bei
Herrn Dr Berger für die konstruktive
Beratung bei Herrn Perli bitte richten
Sie es ihm aus ich danke Ihnen herzlich
für die Unterstützung der Haushalt 2023
stärkt unsere Sicherheit meine Damen und
Herren gerade in Zeiten neuer Bedrohung
und massiver geopolitischer Veränderung
ist es ein wichtiger wichtiges Zeichen
die Ampel sorgt für mehr Sicherheit
vielen Dank meine Damen und Herren
die
bundesinnenministerin war das hat hier
viel Applaus bekommen bei der
Vorstellung ihres Einzelplans bei der
Verteidigung ihres Einzelplans direkt
antworten würden um Gottfried kurio der
innenpolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
zwei Stellen der Milliarden kosten
dieser Zuwanderungspolitik sind noch
nicht mal das Schlimmste laut Statistik
überproportionale Kriminalität in
Zuwanderer und Ausländergruppen durch
ihren bevölkerungsumbau ist das Tragen
von Messern zur Jugendkultur geworden
20.000 Messerattacken in einem Jahr dort
soll unduldsame Gewaltbereitschaft
gegenüber Frauen anderen Religionen dem
Täter und seine Gruppe eine eingebildete
Ehre bezeugen das alles gehört nicht
nach Deutschland meine Damen und Herren
Kriminalität Wohnungsnot Milliarden
kosten diese Migrationspolitik verletzt
massiv deutsche Interessen aber
hunderttausende Migranten durch
beispiellose Sozialleistungen angelockt
ziehen durch sichere Länder und werden
uns dann an den Grenzen als fliehende
aufgelötigt dafür finanzieren sie extra
private schlepperschiffe die neuesten
pulfaktor das erhöhte Bürgergeld
abzugreifen wird noch mehr illegale
locken lieber ein Geschenk des
Grundeinkommen als im Heimatland
arbeiten zu müssen wir sagen Grenzen
sichern Anreize runter Abschiebungen
endlich durchführen hier werden jedes
Jahr Milliarden verbrannt und letztlich
doch nur schuldlasten aufgehäuft sie
leben auf Kosten unserer Kinder sie
Türmen nur immer neue Mauersteine auf
für deren schuldgefängnis schon bis
Oktober sind 20.000 Migranten mega
kommen als 20 15 dieses Jahr werden über
200.000 erwartet aber Ministerin Feser
stellt Infos zu zahlen und Routen nicht
mehr auf die Polizei Seite die Realität
könnte nur stören sie kämpft lieber in
Katar gegen Homophobie Städte und
Gemeinden sind am Limits schreien nach
einem Stopp gegen den deutschen Amoklauf
schließen Österreich Ungarn Serbien
jetzt einen
antimigrationspakt sie haben genug von
Deutschlands migrationspolitischer
geisterfahrerei dieser Politik muss
Deutschland sich jetzt anschließen
sollte Zuwanderer werden überwiegend
nicht dem Arbeitsmarkt dienen sondern
die Gruppe der Kostgänger vergrößern
unberechtigte werden nicht abgeschoben
der sozialtourismus die europäische
Binnenmigration wird nicht blockiert
überall sehenden Auges ins Unheil das
ist diese Regierung meine Damen und
Herren
wer die aufenthaltsvoraussetzung
definitiv nicht erfüllt darf einfach
trotzdem bleiben sie nennen es Chance
eine Chance zu rechtsumgebung die
erlaubt der Staatsbürgerschaft wird auf
kurzfristige Automatik gestellt eine
Arbeitsmarktintegration wird gar nicht
mehr erwartet dafür sollen die
importierten Massen in einem
alimentierten Prekariats her versteckt
werden die illeralität des Vorgangs wird
sprachlich vertuscht man schaltet von
illegal auf erregulär von fluchtnachweis
auf
migrations-arbeitswillig versus Abzocker
unsichtbar gemacht werden mit einem
bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen dessen
erste Stufe Bürgergeld genannt wird
tatsächlich aber nicht Staatsbürgern zu
grundsätzlicher alimentation verhelfen
soll durch hinterherwerfen der
Staatsbürgerschaft soll mit diesem Herr
ausländischer Sozialhilfeempfänger
Deutschland dann im Sinne des
globalistischen Umbaus regiert werden
gegen die Interessen der eigenen Bürger
wir sagen zum Schluss damit deutsches
Geld für deutsche Bürger meine Damen und
Herren
die ampelkoalitionäre sind sich in
diesen Zielen einig auch die Union hat
mitgemacht migrationspakt Grenzöffnung
immer mehr Abschiebung bei immer mehr
Migranten sie waren immer vorne mit
dabei versprachen sich den Beifall der
linkspresse wenn sich dann plötzlich
restriktiver gibt will rechts blinken um
links abzubiegen solange sie ihre
Mehrheiten in den Ländern mit den
Deutschland vernichten bauen und im Bund
das selber erhoffen ein solange entlarvt
sich das Vorspielen konservativer
Positionen als Werder deutschung für so
eine Politik gegen das eigene Volk soll
der meinungskorridor eingeengt werden
durch Netzzensur öffentlich-rechtliche
Regierungspropaganda durch einen
politisch operierenden Verfassungsschutz
für den ist Klima Terrorismus okay mit
erstrebter regierungsnötung durch
Straftaten aber die Forderung nach
jahrzehntelang rechtsgültigen
einbürgerungsbeschränkungen wird als
extremistisch deformiert was für ein
hohen was für ein Amtsmissbrauch die
Bürger werden Ihnen dafür die Quittung
verpassen in Berlin geht es am 12
februar gegen die Ausbreitung der
deutschen durch die umsiedlungsmafia
Gegen muss nur durch illegale Migration
für bezahlbare Energie ohne
Schuldenexplosion ich danke Ihnen
Gottfried kurio war das hat sich hier in
seiner Rede auf an den Teilaspekt
Zuwanderung konzentriert der für den
natürlich auch das Innenministerium mit
zuständig ist Tina Winkelmann spricht
nur für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
die Sportlerinnen
jetzt einfach wieder über Fakten das ist
glaube besser für uns alle im Fußball
Europameisterinnen em Gold für unsere
spindelstaffel und die para Badminton
Spieler Weltmeister im Doppel und so
weiter und so weiter also ein sehr
erfolgreiches Jahr übrigens waren unsere
para Sportlerinnen dieses Jahr so
erfolgreich wie nie und das muss auch
mal gesagt werden
da lacht das Herz und es zeigt
Deutschland ist eine Sportnation und
deshalb mehr Sport Großveranstaltungen
vor heimischen Publikum zusammen mit
unseren Athletinnen und Athleten und
genau da spiegelt sich auch in diesem
Haushalt wieder wir beschließen diese
Woche ein mehr für den Behindertensport
mehr für die Forschung am iat in Leipzig
mehr für die dopingopferhilfe und
erstmals Mittel für die
Prävention von Rechtsextremismus im
Sport überfällig aber mit uns kommt das
Programm und darüber freuen wir uns
mehr für den Sport in Deutschland dafür
ein Dank an unsere haushälter:innen
und hier sieht man ganz klar unsere
Handschrift wir schauen eben nicht nur
auf den Glanz der Medaillen sondern
kümmern uns auch um die Athletinnen und
Athleten wir schauen auch dahin wo es
weh tut denn wieder einmal wurde dieses
Jahr schwere Missbrauchsfälle im Sport
aufgedeckt und wieder gab es keine
staatliche Anlaufstelle der die
Betroffenen Athletinnen und Athleten
genug Vertrauen geschenkt haben wir als
Ampel ändern das jetzt und mit der
Gründung des Trägers Vereins durch die
Ministerin und vielen Dank dafür und die
Mittel aus dem Haushalt schaffen wir die
Grundlage für das Zentrum safe Sport und
das ist wichtig und auch schon lange
überfällig
ich begrüße sehr was der DOSB und die
Verbände auf die Beine gestellt haben
für einen umfassenden Schutz unserer
Athletinnen und Athleten braucht es aber
noch Verbesserungen und wir als Ampel
stehen da auch in Zukunft voll an der
Seite des Sports und nach der
missglückten spitzensportreform von 2016
müssen wir auch hier anpacken und
deshalb bringen wir als Ampel ein Sport
fördergesetz auf den Weg gemeinsam
formuliert die Ziele und verbindliche
Maßnahmen zusammen mit den Athletinnen
und Athleten damit bringen wir die
sportdeutschland auf einen
zukunftsfähigen weg und für die Rechte
und Beteiligung der Athletinnen und
Athleten werden wir uns im weiteren
Prozess stark machen
denn unsere Spitzensportlerinnen und
Spitzensportler wirken als Vorbilder für
den Breitensport für fairnessvielfalt
und Solidarität und damit wären wir beim
Thema Vielfalt Toleranz ach was sage ich
wir sprechen hier von Menschenrechten
von uns als Gesellschaft wir sind Bund
und vielfältig eine one love-binde die
zur Diskussion gestellt wird verbannt
und das Tragen und das Aktionen gestellt
wird ja geil
die Weltmeisterschaft als Trauerspiel
daran wird so auf Hochtouren gearbeitet
aber wir lassen uns ja nicht sagen was
wir wann als Zeichen unsere Vielfalt
tragen ein Internet hat international
anerkanntes Zeichen starke Sportlerinnen
und Sportler haben ihre eigene Meinung
und die sollen sie nach außen tragen
können eine WM soll ein internationales
Sportfest sein für alle egal wen man
liebt
wir wollen dass die Sportlerinnen und
Sportler sicher und frei in Wettkampf
messen können
und dieser Haushalt gibt uns auch Kraft
die nächste Strecke gut zu bewältigen
denn unser Ziel bleibt klar fördern wo
erforderlich Prävention und Aufklärung
wohl nötig an der Seite des Sports danke
schön
vielen Dank Frau Kolleginnen
Tina Winkelmann war das
hiermit deutlich lokalkulorit in der
Stimme die sportpolitische Sprecherin
der Bündnis Grünen und der nächste
Redner ist andere Hahn sportpolitischer
Sprecher der Linksfraktion
herr Präsident die Fußball-WM in Katar
stand von Anfang an unter keinen guten
Stern und das nicht nur wegen der
dortigen Menschenrechtsverletzung und
dem unsäglichen Agieren der FIFA und nun
hat auch noch die deutsche Mannschaft
der erste Spiel verloren unser
Sportministerin nennt sich Weser war
gestern vor Ort hat auch tapfer eine One
Love Binde getragen und kümmert sich Udo
Hinsch und fast rührend um den
Profifußball aber der Sportteil des nun
zur Abstimmung stehen im Bundeshaushalt
lässt auch für die kommenden Jahre kaum
auf spürbare Verbesserung hoffen dass
dieser Tage präsentierte gruppenkonzept
zur Reform des Spitzensportförderung
wurde nicht nur an den Athleten und am
Sportausschuss vorbei erarbeitet sondern
gibt auch auf zentrale Fragen keine
Antworten Mut und kraftlos ist aus
meiner Sicht auch das Engagement der
Bundesregierung wenn es um die
Unterstützung des Breitensports geht das
war während der corona-pandemie schon so
zeichnet sich jetzt für die Bewältigung
die aktuellen Energiekrise wieder ab und
geht weiterhin bis zu einer völlig
unbefriedigen Situation vieler
Sportstätten und Schwimmbäder im Land
warum Frau Feser kann die
kulturstaatsministerin Claudia Roth
rückwirkend einen Kulturfonds Energie in
Höhe von einer Milliarde Euro
bereitstellen und sie stehen für den
Sport mit leeren Taschen da und auf der
einen Seite werden für Sport
Großveranstaltungen und das relativ
kleine militärsportfest Invictus Games
zig Millionen Euro ausgegeben
andererseits bleibt bei bis heute
existenziell bedrohten Sportvereinen die
Tür zum härtefallfonds bei extremsten
Energiepreissteigerungen verschlossen
diese Entscheidung muss dringend
korrigiert werden
dass bei der beim Katastrophenschutz die
ursprünglich geplanten drastischen
Kürzungen beim THW auch auf unseren
Druck in teilweise zurückgenommen wurden
begrüßen wir denn wir müssen das
Ehrenamt gerade jetzt Stärken letzte
Bemerkung anstatt wie geplant hunderte
Millionen in dieser Sanierung und die
Neubau von Immobilien für
Bundesnachrichtendienst und den
Verfassungsschutz auszugeben sollte
dieses Geld lieber für Soziales den
Sport und auch den zivilen
Katastrophenschutz angelegt werden dort
ist es deutlich besser investiert
andere Hahn hat sich hier natürlich auch
noch mal auf Katar bezogen die
Nationalmannschaft durfte da ja nicht
die One Love Binde tragen also hat es
die Innenministerin gemacht und das
wurde hier noch mal gewertschätzt
Konstantin coole stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzen der FDP
Redner haben ja hier schon über das
Thema Migration gesprochen und dazu will
ich einmal klarstellen wir werden bis
Ende 2022 voraussichtlich knapp 200.000
Erstanträge auf Asyl in Deutschland
haben das sind hohe Zahlen aber diese
Zahlen sind auch weit entfernt von den
Spitzen Zahlen in
2015/2016 und deswegen muss man diese
Situation als eine eigene Situation in
dieser Zeit bewerten liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aber da aber die besondere
Situation die wir haben ist dass wir
ganz viele Antragsteller haben aus dem
Irak aus Syrien und aus Afghanistan und
dass diese Antragsteller sich mischen in
der Verantwortlichkeit der Kommunen mit
zahlreichen Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern
und diese Kombination aus den
Erstanträgen auf Asyl und den Ukrainern
das stellt die Kommunen vor besondere
Herausforderungen und es ist richtig wir
dürfen als Bund die Kommunen in dieser
Situation nicht alleine lassen und
deswegen ist es gut und richtig dass der
Bund die Kommunen finanziell unterstützt
er tut das nicht im Rahmen des
Bundeshaushalts sondern im Rahmen der
Umsatzsteuerverteilung es ist richtig
dass hier die Kommunen unterstützt
werden denn alleine werden sie das nicht
schaffen mit dieser schwierigen
Situation fertig zu werden
meine Damen und Herren ich mache mir ein
bisschen Sorgen dass wir wenn wir über
Migrationspolitik sprechen das wäre dann
nur über Krisen sprechen wir müssen aber
auch den Fokus der Migrationspolitik mal
klar Kriegen in diesem Land und der
Fokus muss sein dass wir mehr reguläre
und weniger irreguläre Migration
brauchen und deswegen ist es gut dass
diese Ampelkoalition schon bald den
Chancen Aufenthalt auf den Weg bringen
denn der sorgt für mehr Integration in
den Arbeitsmarkt deswegen ist es gut
dass diese Ampelkoalition schon bald ein
Eckpunktepapier zur Einwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt beschließen wird denn das
ist das was unsere Wirtschaft unser Land
braucht und deswegen ist es auch gut
dass diese Ampelkoalition schon bald die
Asylverfahren beschleunigen wird damit
klar ist ob Menschen einen
Aufenthaltstitel in Deutschland haben
oder ob sie keinen haben und ich will
dazu auch sagen denn es so ist dass
Menschen keinen Aufenthaltstitel keinen
Anspruch Aufenthalt haben dann muss auch
die Rückkehr in das Heimatland der
Regelfall sein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und deswegen und deswegen bin
ich sehr dafür dass wir miteinander auch
darüber sprechen wie Bund und Länder bei
Abschiebungen noch besser
zusammenarbeiten können meine Damen und
Herren liebe Frau bundesinnenministerin
sie sind ja gerade in der Türkei gewesen
und ich finde das richtig weil wir
werden dieses Thema Migration nicht
alleine lösen und das was die Türkei da
macht die unwürdige Behandlung von
Syrern die unwürdige Behandlung von
Afghanen das ist doch ein wesentlicher
triebfaktor dafür warum die Zahlen auch
in Deutschland und Europa hochgehen
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir denen
da deutlich machen in der Türkei wir
nehmen das nicht hin und wir wollen da
eine andere Politik auch eine
Zusammenarbeit mit der Türkei wenn man
über die Türkei spricht dann muss man
sich aber auch klar machen und das ist
das zweite Thema was ich kurz ansprechen
möchte dass die Türkei genau wie andere
Staaten hier in Deutschland als
autoritär regierter Staat unmittelbar
Einfluss nimmt auf unsere Politik ich
will einmal erwähnen die sogenannte UID
die Union internationaler Demokraten
eine Vereinigung die vom
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird und
die gezielt Terror und Druck machen soll
auf die Menschen in türkischstämmigen
Communitys in Deutschland das wird
gemacht über die UID das wird gemacht
über TRT Deutsch das wird gemacht über
die tipp-moscheen und all das müssen wir
bekämpfen das ist hinderlich für
Integration deswegen müssen wir uns auch
darum kümmern dass Imame in Deutschland
ausgebildet werden und nicht
ferngesteuert werden aus der Türkei
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn man
sich anschaut welche autoritären Staaten
das noch machen China über sogenannte
Polizeistationen der Iran
übereinrichtungen wie das IZH in Hamburg
oder auch Russland über zahlreiche
Cyberattacken dann ist es richtig an
unserer Widerstandskraft zu arbeiten das
sollten wir tun aber wir sollten niemals
vergessen mit wem wir es bei
autoritärischen Regime ähm mit dem was
da zu tun haben und müssen ganz deutlich
machen dass sich die liberale Demokratie
auch gegen diese Versuche der
Unterwanderung verteidigen wird liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen vielen Dank
Konstantin coole hat hier auch die
kritische Infrastruktur angesprochen
auch da soll es ein Eckpunktepapier für
ein neues dachgesetz gibt es dort schon
und da werden mindestens 11 Sektoren wie
zum Beispiel Abwasser oder auch Verkehr
und Bankwesen genannt als kritische
Infrastruktur Josef Ostern und für die
Unionsfraktion
herr Präsident verehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
verehrte Frau Ministerin ich habe ihn
natürlich eben eine aufmerksam zugehört
und habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck
gewonnen dass sie während ihrer Reisen
nach Katar den Blick für die Realitäten
in Deutschland ein Stück weit verloren
haben ich wollte das eigentlich gar
nicht kritisieren aber natürlich haben
wir in Deutschland eine kritische
migrationslage wenn Sie das in Frage
stellen dann haben Sie den Bürgermeister
und Landräten in unserem Land offenbar
nicht zugehört ich kann Ihnen nur
empfehlen reden Sie mit diesen Menschen
und hören Sie Ihnen aufmerksam zu wir
haben eine kritische Situation in
unserem Land und meine sehr geehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus der
Ampelkoalition wenn ich insbesondere den
Haushältern hierzu gehört habe dann
gewinne ich den Eindruck dass die
Koalition nur noch in Sondervermögen
denkt dort werden Prioritäten gesetzt
alles andere bleibt irgendwie so wie es
ist
das ist keine Haushaltspolitik sondern
es geht darum Prioritäten innerhalb des
allgemeinen Haushalts zu setzen und
genau das passiert zu wenig und ganz
besonders wären zwei Teilhaushalte in
diesem Jahr gefordert das ist natürlich
Inneres und Verteidigung und den beiden
Bereichen sinken die Haushaltsansätze
das ist falsche Prioritätensetzung meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und dabei muss es doch mehr denn jeder
umgehen gerade im Bereich der inneren
Sicherheit aktuell Schwerpunkte zu
setzen und da spielt unsere
Bundespolizei eine ganz zentrale Rolle
zunehmende Bedrohungslagen steigende
Zahlen von links und Rechtsextremismus
Anschläge auf unsere Infrastruktur wir
stehen vor gewaltigen Herausforderungen
und wir müssen mehr in unsere Sicherheit
investieren und das ist nur ein Aspekt
der für mich dafür spricht dass wir über
dieses Jahr hinaus dringend den
personellen aufwuchs bei der
Bundespolizei fortsetzen müssen diese
aufwuchs muss weitergehen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren verehrte
Ministerin
und das gilt eben auch für die
Herausforderung in Zusammenhang mit der
Migration die Bundespolizei ist ja auch
für Rückführungen mit zuständig und hier
ist ein Schwerpunkt notwendig und Herr
Kohle sie haben da eben viel Richtiges
zum Thema Rückführungen gesagt aber ich
musste rückfahren fragen was ist denn
mit dem rückführungsbeauftragten den
diese Regierung groß angekündigt hat
weit und breit keine Botschaft zu dieser
Frage
ich will aber bei der Bundespolizei
bleiben wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
dort in den nächsten Jahren eine
erhebliche ruhestandswelle auf die
Bundespolizei zurollt und auch das ist
ein Argument dass hier der Aufwuchs
weitergehen muss verehrte Frau
Ministerin das ist aber offensichtlich
nicht ihr Plan diesen Weg vorzusetzen
ganz im Gegenteil sie bauen gerade in
diesen Wochen massiv aus und
fortbildungskapazitäten bei der
Bundespolizei ab die Ausbildungsstätte
in Bielefeld wird aufgelöst an den
Standort in den Dienst Swisttal und
Rotenburg an der Fulda werden
Ausbildungskapazitäten zum Teil
erheblich reduziert hier gab es ganz
offensichtlich einspardruck aus Ihrem
Hause und das ist ein falsches Signal
wir brauchen in Zukunft mehr
Polizistinnen und Polizisten in
Deutschland und wir benötigen mehr aus
und Fortbildung bei der Bundespolizei
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
ich will aber noch ein weiteres Thema
ansprechen in schwierigen Zeiten müssen
die Menschen darauf vertrauen können
dass der Staat handlungsfähig ist und
Frau Feser als bundesinnenministerin
sind sie ja auch für wesentliche Fragen
der Digitalisierung in unserem Land
zuständig ein Aufgabenfeld bei dem man
von ihnen aber wenig bis gar nichts hört
auch heute nicht verehrte Frau
Ministerin aber gerade bei der
Digitalisierung der öffentlichen
Verwaltung ist auf ist weiterhin eine
große Baustelle es fehlen Signale wie es
mit dem online-zugangsgesetz weitergeht
rechtlich und finanziell auch die Pläne
zu den digitalen Identitäten und zur
Register Modernisierung bleiben wage wir
dürfen uns hier Frau Ministerin keinen
Stillstand leisten
meine Damen meine Herren in jeder großen
Krise liegen eben aber immer auch große
Chancen und die Chancen Frau Ministerin
die öffentliche Verwaltung in
Deutschland entscheidend
weiterzuentwickeln und zu modernisieren
die war vielleicht noch nie so groß wie
jetzt und deshalb die Bitte und die
Aufforderung nutzen Sie dieses
Zeitfenster verehrte Frau Ministerin und
in schwierigen Zeiten meine sehr
geehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen kommt
es mir denn jeder darauf an dass die
Menschen Vertrauen haben Vertrauen in
ein sicheres persönliches Umfeld und
Vertrauen in einen funktionierenden und
handlungsfähigen Staat beide Ansprüchen
wird diese Haushalt jedenfalls nicht
gerecht
vielen Dank natürlich Ostern
Dirk Wiese ist schon auf dem Weg zum
Pult erster stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Frau
Bundesministerin fesak Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Sport der Fußball ist nicht
unpolitisch der Fußball steht für Werte
wer aber jegliche Werte verloren hat und
das muss man in diesen Tagen sagen bei
allen Diskussionen das ist die FIFA mit
ihrem Präsidenten Infantino und ich sage
dass der deutlich liebe Frau
Bundesministerin ich bin Ihnen dankbar
für ihr starkes Zeichen gestern in Katar
und dieser FIFA Präsident gehört
abgelöst der ist nicht mehr tragbar
der Blick auf den Haushalt des
Bundesinnenministeriums ist positiv es
sind fast 13,1 Milliarden Euro der für
die innere Sicherheit zukünftig zur
Verfügung stellen zur Verfügung steht
und ich bin dankbar gerade den
Haushälterinnen und Haushältern der
koalitionsfraktion dass sie im Laufe der
Lesung seit der ersten Lesung viele
wichtige Punkte noch auf den Weg
gebracht haben ich will das ganz
deutlich betonen es war richtig genau
hinzuschauen dass wir beim THW
zusätzliche Mittel bereitstellen dass
wir zusätzliche Mittel im Bereich des
Katastrophenschutzes bereitstellen dass
wir den Aufbau SMS Zell broadcast vorbei
bringen das sind wichtige Entscheidungen
die die koalitionsfraktion für die
innere Sicherheit macht und da gebührt
den Haushältern ein großes Dankeschön
dieser Ampelkoalition
und ich will auch ganz deutlich sagen
dass ich es absolut richtig halte dass
wir auch in bei einigen Punkten die
kritisiert worden sind von der
Opposition sehr schnell wichtige
Entscheidungen treffen es ist richtig
dass wir als Ampelkoalition uns
verabredet haben eine Reform des
bundespolizeigesetzes das mit ihnen
übrigens nicht möglich gewesen ist in
der letzten Legislatur gemeinsam auf den
Weg bringen das ist ein starkes Signal
für die Bundespolizei das wird auf den
Weg gebracht und wir werden auch
gemeinsam mit dem
Bundesfinanzministerium die Ruhe
gehaltsfähigkeit der Polizei Zulage auf
den Weg bringen das haben wir vereinbart
und das werden wir auch tun da wir diese
Ampelkoalition liefern
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach 16
Jahren Union in der Innenpolitik ist es
auch richtig Lebensrealitäten in diesem
Land endlich anzuerkennen und der
Kollege Konstantin Kuhle hat es
angesprochen wir wollen als
Ampelkoalition den Menschen die lange
bei uns sind die hier sind die zu diesem
Land gehören mit dem Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht eine Möglichkeit geben
eine klare Bleibeperspektive in diesem
Land zu bekommen das ist richtig das
bringen wir gemeinsam auf den Weg und
auch die Reformen beim Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz erkennen
Lebensrealitäten an wir brauchen das um
auch bei uns im Land die Fachkräfte
Lücke die Arbeitskräfte Lücke zu
schließen da liefern wir als
Ampelkoalition das war mit ihnen 16
Jahre lang nicht möglich gewesen
und ich muss das schon sagen weil ich
das gerade vom Kollegen Oster gehört
habe dass man nur weil man mal nicht im
Land ist Realitäten nicht anerkennt ich
will das noch mal sagen zu aktuellen
migrationslage ja das ist das ist
herausfordernd keine Frage aber nochmal
wer Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine also
sozialtouristen diffamiert wie ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender Friedrich Merz der
hat die Realitäten definitiv nicht
anerkannt das war schäbig und da habe
ich nichts von ihnen heute in der
Debatte dazu gehört
und dann will ich ja noch mal ein
interessanten an Punkt erwähnen weil die
Union ja an vielen Stellen immer sagt
das Thema innere Sicherheit das ist
ihnen wichtig der Rechtsstaat klare
Regeln Normen und Ordnung dann werfe ich
einen Blick nach Baden-Württemberg dort
gibt es ein Innenminister Strobel dieser
Innenminister Strobel in
Baden-Württemberg sagen wir mal so
richtig fragwürdig unterwegs dann
bekommt dieser Kollege Strobel in
Baden-Württemberg eine Geldauflage wo ja
mir einige sagen könnte wenn man ein
bisschen Rückhalt hat müsste man als
Innenminister eigentlich sein Gut schon
längst genommen haben und dann stellt
sich dieser Innenminister der Union hin
und verkauft als eine gutmütige Spende
vor der Weihnachtszeit also liebe Union
wenn das Innere Sicherheit der cdu/csu
ist dann kann ich nur sagen gut dass die
Ampelkoalition nach 16 Jahren hier
Verantwortung übernommen hat vielen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
vielen Dank Kollege Luise
als nächster Redner der Kollege Klaus
stöber afd-fraktionismus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für die Bedeutung des Sports hier im der
Politik und im Haushalt nein braucht
Millionen für den Sport sind nicht
ausreichend das sind 0,06 Prozent des
Haushalts das ist lächerlich ich möchte
auch über Katar sprechen das hört schon
einiges mal gesprochen worden
angesichts der
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in diesem
Land hätte eine WM in diesem Land nie
stattfinden dürfen die Fehler sind
sicherlich schon vor 12 Jahren gefasst
worden bei der Vergabe aber wir hätten
die Chance gehabt diesen Fehler zu
korrigieren indem man die europäischen
Länder und nach einigen andere Staaten
nicht dorthin gefahren werden dieses
pmotivieren müssen dass wir ein viel
größerer Schaden gewesen sowohl für die
Scheichs als auch für die korrupte FIFA
als dieses Verhalten der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft das war sicherlich
dieser Auftritt der Nationalmannschaft
früher waren früher waren
Nationalspieler Vorbilder für die Jugend
das sind sie nicht mehr wie soll sich
die Jugend an solchen Leuten orientieren
die eine Vorbereitung einer WM da
eigentlich besteht sich die diskutieren
ob sie eine Binde tragen oder nicht das
ist lächerlich die Profis werden nächste
Woche zurückfliegen zurückbleibt der
Amateursport der oder dieser Misere
leiden wird wir haben einen Missstand in
Deutschland wir haben 35 Millionen
Rückstand beim Sportstättenbau ja es ist
in erster Linie ein kommunales Problem
aber die Kommunen können dieses Problem
nicht allein lösen wir müssen das Bund
ein kommunales Programm auf dem Weg
bringen wir haben als AFD ungefähr 20
Anträge Rennen dieser Legislatur auf dem
Weg gebracht nächste Woche werden wir
unter anderem über Olympia sprechen ja
ich würde mir wünschen dass andere
Fraktionen dieses Thema Sport auch mehr
in ihren Augenschein nehmen be für mich
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin
wisperkan Fraktion bin ich 19
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Leipziger Autoritarismus Studie und
die mittelstudie bestätigen uns
eigentlich alle paar Jahre Rassismus
braucht keine Nazis die Mitte beherrscht
ihn auch Tag für Tag müssen sich
politisch engagierte wären gegen
Bedrohungen und gegen Hetze Tag für Tag
müssen nicht weiß und migrantisch
gelesene Personen sich Sorgen machen um
ihre körperliche Sicherheit und Tag für
Tag
sägt die rechte Seite dieses Plenums an
den Grundpfeilern unserer Demokratie
und wenn Sie heute einen Antrag stellen
zu Finanzierung eines
verfassungsfeindlichen Think Tanks dann
wird der demokratische Teil dieses
Plenums zusammenstehen doch dieses
entschlossen und gemeinsame
zusammenstehen auch keine
Selbstverständlichkeit mehr früher hieß
es aus den Seiten aus der Reihen der
Union mit uns gibt es eine Brandmauer
gegen die AFD doch wo ist diese große
Brandmauer gegen Rechts wenn wo sind die
aufschreibe wenn in Thüringen ihre
Parteien mit FaschistInnen und
Faschisten zusammenarbeitet wo sind
diese aufschreibe wenn in der Umgebung
wenn in Deutschland wieder geflüchteten
Unterkünfte brennen ihr Schweigen ist
beschämt und umso Geschenke
[Applaus]
von März zur Terrorismus und zu
vermeintlicher Öko-Diktatur wenn man
sich vor ein SUV klebt und so nervig da
diese Proteste sind das seine
Relativierung des echten rechten
Terrorismus den wir in Deutschland schon
erlebt haben
mit diesem Haushalt gehen wir endlich
einen anderen Weg wir machen eine
Innenpolitik für die Gesamtgesellschaft
wir setzen Schwerpunkte im Bereich
Rassismus im Bereich Rechtsextremismus
gegen Hass und Hetze zum Beispiel indem
wir die politische Bildung stärken indem
wir endlich eine einen Ort schaffen für
die Änderung für Betroffene des NSU und
für die Aufarbeitung des rechts-terrors
Deutschlands Verantwortliche in der
Vergangenheit waren wahnsinnig gut darin
nach der NSU selbst Enttarnung nach
Hanau und nach Halle erschüttert zu sein
von rechter Gewalt ins faktische handeln
was erkennbare Verbesserung von
gesellschaftlicher oder politischer
Konsequenz war hat es danach nie gegeben
unser Land ist wahnsinnig gut darin in
einzelnen Momenten Betroffenheit zu
äußern jetzt auch in den aktuellen
Diskussionen zur One Love findet bei der
WM doch nach der Sensation wann sie
immer der Weltmeister
ignorieren
das wird es mit uns als Ampel so nicht
geben wir ziehen endlich Schüsse und
Schlüsse und Konsequenzen dass das
bitter notwendig ist liegt auch daran
dass es Parteien in diesem Haus gibt die
Stimmung machen mit Hass und Hetze zum
eigenen Vorteil vielen Dank
nun der Fraktionslose Matthias Helfrich
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren es
ist Dienstag mittag der 18 Oktober 2022
ein Mann rastet aus er greift zu einem
langen Messer töte zwei Unschuldige
verletzt eine weitere Person einem Opfer
hat er den Unterarm ab die Todesursachen
laut Obduktion Stich inhaltsjunge und
Brustkorb inneres und äußeres verbluten
der Täter soll laut Zeugenaussagen
allahu akbar gerufen haben erst 25
Somalia kam 2015 nach Deutschland wie
man da sich noch kaputt machen kann
angesichts solcher goldtaten kann ich
nicht nachvollziehen vor Cador während
Politiker und die sogenannte
Zivilgesellschaft nach der Blut Tat von
Ludwigshafener 02 oder aber Mahnwachen
gegen Rechts abhielten Entsetzen und
Verzweiflung bei den Angehörigen und
Nachbarn ein Vater musste sein
niedergestochenen Sohn auf der Straße
sterben sehen die anhaltende
Massenzuwanderung ist die Kondition die
Bedingungen nicht hinweg gedacht werden
kann ohne dass diese grausamen glutaten
entfielen politische Lerneffekte keine
sie setzen ihre migrationspolitische
Agenda fort Stichwort
chancenaufenthaltsrecht hierdurch wird
der hohe Bedarf an Migrationsberatung so
heißt es in ihrem Einzelplan noch weiter
erhöht weitere Millionen an
steuervermögen werden in ihrem
Einzelplan für solche Leistungen
veranschlagt das ist inzwischen einen
hohen dass ihr Ministerium Frau
Ministerin Fräser den Begriff Heimat im
Namen trägt Heimweh Ministerium wäre
wohl ehrlicher Heimweh in den eigenen
Städten das ist das Gefühl was immer
mehr Menschen in westdeutschen
Ballungsgebieten bewegt in meiner
Heimatstadt Dortmund vergeht keine Woche
ohne Messerstechereien Schießereien
Vergewaltigung hier hilft es auch nicht
wenn die Polizei anlasslose Kontrollen
durchführt Kameras aufstellt oder
Dauerpräsenz zeigt Migranten die mit
Messern ja Macheten bewaffnet sind sind
in meiner Heimatstadt Alltag allein 7371
messerstraftaten hat die Polizei NRW
inzwischen zwischen Januar 22 und Juni
222 registriert immer häufiger kommen
die Opfer zu Tode
41,7 Prozent der Tatverdächtigen haben
kein deutschen Pass das einst sichere
Deutschland verblasst es bleiben
fragmentierte parallel und gegen
gesellschaftlich an französische bonius
oder schwedische Städterinnen links
sehen sich auch all jene Einwanderer
nach dem alten Deutschland zurück was
sie als neue Heimat kennenlernen durften
es steht hier alles auf dem Spiel wollen
wir noch irgendetwas von Deutschland in
die Zukunft hinüber retten da müssen
nicht unerhebliche Teile der 892
Millionen Euro die für Integration und
Migration veranschlagt sind für
abschiebe Busse abschiebeschiffe und
abschiebeflugzeuge voraus gehabt werden
für alle die Säbel Selbstschutz und
mache jeden mutumbus gibt es nur einen
Weg Polizei Richter Knast Ticket in die
Heimat vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Sandra
buchendorfer Licht FDP-Fraktion Sandra
bubendorfer Licht ist die
religionspolitische Sprecherin der
Liberalen im Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe Frau
Ministerin Faeser liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bevor ich zum entsprechenden
Einzelplan nur Sex komme möchte ich mich
noch mal aufs herzlichste bei den
zuständigen Hauseltern für den
unermüdlichen Einsatz bedanken
ebenso möchte ich zum Schluss hier noch
ein paar Dinge in Sachen Haushalt
speziell in Bevölkerungsschutz
ansprechen und klarstellen die
abenteuerliche Legenden Bildung speziell
von Seiten der Union kann ich so nicht
unkommentiert lassen und wenn jemand
Versäumnisse in der etalentwicklung in
Bevölkerungsschutz zu verschulden hat
dann sie liebe Union denn Fakt ist im
Vergleich zu 2019 also seit dem Herr
Seehofer nur noch im verwaltungsmodus
war sind die Haushaltsmittel des
Bundesamtes für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe sowie der Technischen
Hilfswerks völlig zu Recht enorm
angewachsen das Budget des Baby Karl lag
im Jahr 2019 bei 145 Millionen Euro für
das Jahr 2023 sind 174 Millionen Euro
vorgesehen das ist eine Steigerung von
20%. beim THW Land Haushaltsvolumen im
Jahr 2019 bei 282 Millionen Euro für das
Jahr 2023 sind 386 Millionen Euro
vorgesehen das ist eine Steigerung von
fast 40 Prozent und in der
Bereinigungssitzung haben wir den Etage
des Bevölkerungsschutzes noch mal mit 80
Millionen gestärkt
der Eindruck
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
massiv und Kürzungen früher das den
auslaufenden Konjunkturprogrammen und
das wissen sie ganz genau aber in Zeiten
von polykrisen muss das Geld eben
sorgsam ausgegeben werden und
Konjunkturprogramme können nicht dauernd
laufen das ist eine Verpflichtung
gegenüber den kommenden Generationen und
es ist einfach unredlich und für eine
den eigenen Ansprüchen nach Volkspartei
unwürdig wenn man den die Menschen in
diesem Land so hinter die Fichten führt
und sie von der Union haben sich
scheinbar vollkommen von seriöser
Haushaltspolitik verabschiedet und die
Tatsache das sind sofort 16 Jahre lang
die Verantwortung in BMI hatten und den
Bevölkerungsschutz kaputt gespart haben
Haut den fast wirklich den Boden aus
Funktionäre von THW bedanken sie
außerordentlich bei uns dafür dass wir
nun endlich anpacken und dass es
vorangeht wir als fortschrittskoalition
geben den Bevölkerungsschutz den
Stellenwert den er verdient und den
haben sie ihm eben nicht gegeben und
auch an der Ausstattung an der Basis und
dem Ehrenamt wird Rechnung getragen
Problem hierbei ist immer aber noch der
Investitions da aber all das lässt sich
nicht in einem Haushalt aufholen aber
seien Sie versichert dass wir in
kommenden Jahren auf diesen wichtigen
Entwicklungen aufbauen werden herzlichen
Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kolleginnen
jetzt hatte ich das Wort mechthilde
Wittmann hat jetzt das Wort eigentlich
hatte sie fünf Minuten Redezeit weil
aber ihre Vorrednerin länger gesprochen
hat wurde ihr eine Minute abgezogen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen trotz meiner
verkürzten Redezeiten muss ich eines
vorweg schicken Frau Kahn
ich verbitte mir namens meiner Fraktion
namens aller unionsmitglieder und Namens
des großen mehrheits der Bevölkerung
ihre Vermischung unserer Politik mit der
brennenden Flüchtlingsunterkunft in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ich verbitte mir
jede Falschaussage hier es ist eine
Verleumdung und ich gehe davon aus dass
wir diese auch noch mal sehen ich habe
bitte mir das auch im politischen
Diskurs ist nicht jede Ahnungslosigkeit
und Bösartigkeit erlaubt und ich habe
mir bitte mir ebenso
Herr Kollege Wiese wenn Sie glauben dass
sie mit diesem Plattheiten die sie hier
ausgesprochen haben gegen unter anderem
den Herrn Minister Strobel punkten
können dann erspare ich Ihnen und mir
schlicht die voll in Niveaulosigkeit
einfach die Namen aufzuzählen die ich da
aus ihrer Fraktion aufzählen könnte aber
wenn Sie es brauchen gerne
und jetzt komme ich zur Sache Herr
Kollege Kuhle ich habe festgestellt dass
offenkundig die Worte ihres Kollegen
Kubicki dem ich jetzt nicht ins Gesicht
gucken kann leider ähm aber sie machen
es gleich und haben hoffentlich eine
strengen Blick den sie ernten Wirkung
gemacht gezeigt hat sie haben und ich
honoriere das ausdrücklich genau
unterschied zwischen den Schwierigkeiten
die auf uns zukommen aufgrund einer
tatsächlich erhöhten migrationszahlen
und Frau Ministerin ich glaube die ist
ihnen auch bewusst migrationszahlen die
unabhängig von den Ukraine Flüchtlingen
kommen und die unter Umständen
angesichts der immer weitergehenden
Bedrohungslagen auf der Welt sich noch
weiter steigern müssen und für diese
müssen wir eine Antwort finden und wir
müssen eine Antwort finden für eine
möglicherweise Hybride Kriegsführung in
der Ukraine für die Kälte für die
Stromausfälle die dort sind und vor der
verständlich in Aufforderung die Ukraine
zu verlassen vor diesem Hintergrund aber
die Konsequenz ist doch
diese Menschen
hochverständlich bei uns Schutz suchen
werden und wollen und wir darauf
vorbereitet sein müssen und zwar
insbesondere unsere Kommunen die
Kommunen müssen es stemmen nicht wir
hier im vergleichsweise immer noch
warmen Hohenhaus
und wir müssen unterscheiden und das hat
Frau Schäfer halt auch mal wieder nicht
auf die Reihe gekriegt zwischen der
regulären Migration der Einwanderung
durch als Fachkräfte zu uns kommen die
teilweise Arbeitskräfte bei uns sein
können und denen die migrieren aus
Bedrohungslagen da einen Schutzstatus
haben und auch derer gekommen ohne einen
Schutzstatus erreichen zu können und das
müssen wir uns zumuten auch wenn wir
nicht gern mit der Sache konfrontiert
werden Frau Schäfer und deswegen glaube
ich Ihnen dass Sie bei der
Beschleunigung des
Asylverfahrensgesetzes tatsächlich auch
guten Willen sind das sind wir auch das
haben wir auch und ich hoffe sie nicken
weit in unserer Zeit versucht als diese
Andrang kam aber wir glauben dass die
Wege unterschiedlich sind wir glauben
dass eine behördenunabhängige
asylberatung eben nicht die
Konsequenzen hat und vor allen Dingen
aber auch nicht die Konsistenz hat die
wir uns wünschen und wie sie bisher
angesiedelt sind und lassen Sie uns
darüber wirklich in einen sachlichen
Diskurs gehen denn wir müssen es bewält
wenn du nicht einfach nur beschreien
und meine Damen und Herren für die
Fachkräfte haben wir ein hervorragendes
fachkräft der einwanderungsgesetzes
meine Uhr läuft ab ich konnte gar nicht
sagen was ich alles sagen wollte und
diese sollten wir auch umsetzen aber
eines will ich dann schon noch sagen es
wurde gesagt beim Bevölkerungsschutz und
beim THW hätten wir geschlafen und sie
würden hochglättern und sie würden hier
zulegen dann setze ich ihn mal die
Zahlen von die lesen Sie heute Abend bei
einem guten Glas Wein noch mal durch im
ersten Entwurf des Innenministeriums des
EPL 6 gab es bei dem THW eine Kürzung um
29% und beim BBK um 39 %. glauben sie
immer noch sie könnten sagen wir haben
gekürzt und weil wir hier nachhaltig
geworden sind konnte jetzt dazugelegt
werden und deswegen sind wir dankbar
vielen Dank Frau Kollege Wittmann
war das für die Unionsfraktion Ingo
Schäfer kann ihr nun direkt antworten er
sitzt im Ausschuss für Inneres und
Heimat für die Sozialdemokraten
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident
sehr geehrte Frau
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der demokratischen Parteien sehr geehrte
gestern
Krieg in Europa Pandemie Klimakrise
Inflation gefährdete Energieversorgung
und flüchtlingskrise die vielen Krisen
sind eine Bewährungsprobe für unsere
Gesellschaft und die Politik unser
Handeln wird bestimmt vom täglichen
Krisenmanagement das betrifft jeden
einzelnen Menschen in Deutschland wir
alle stehen seit Beginn der Pandemie vor
fast drei Jahren unsere Pläne in Frage
wie schütze ich meine Gesundheit und die
Gesundheit meiner Familie
wie finanziere ich lebensmittelstrom und
Gas das sind die Fragen die die Menschen
in Deutschland und auch uns hier im
Parlament bewegen niemand weiß was
kommen wird doch wir können heute für
das vorsorgen was morgen kommen könnte
was wir als Verantwortlicher
Politikerinnen und Politiker machen
können ist vorsorgen wir werden uns mit
der Mehrheit hier im Hause dafür sorgen
das Leben und die Gesundheit der
Bevölkerung zu schützen das haben wir
während der Pandemie getan und wir
werden das auch weitermachen
als Abgeordneter kann ich dazu beitragen
dass wir alle gut durch den Winter
kommen und unsere Strom- und Gasrechnung
bezahlen können genau dafür hat die
Koalition gesorgt indem wir die Menschen
mit zahlreichen Maßnahmen finanziell
entlasten und unterstützen
seit einem Jahr ist die Politik der
Ampel Koalition vom Prinzip vorsorgen
geprägt wir kümmern uns um den Schutz
der Menschen wirtschaftlich auch bei
Gefahrenabwehr im Inland innenpolitisch
heißt das wir stärken den
Bevölkerungsschutz in Deutschland im
Haushalt 2023 mit 659 Millionen Euro
und die Fehler der
vormalsverantwortlichen korrigieren wir
wie zum Beispiel beteiligt sich das BMI
nun mit zwei Löschflugzeugen am
katastrophenschutzverfahren der EU das
ist europäische Solidarität und wenn bei
uns mal wieder weit und Wiese brennen
haben wir wirksame Mittel zur Hilfe und
das ist die Vorsorge und dazu gehört
auch der Aufbau der im Aufbau
befindlichen zivilschutzreserve sie kam
bereits im Ahrtal und den Tegel zum
Einsatz und Menschen zu versorgen und
unterzubringen und auch das Handy
Warnsystem nehmen wir so schnell wie
möglich im Betrieb alles Sachen die CDU
CSU in den vergangenen 16 Jahren
vernachlässigt haben Liebe Union die
sitzt in einem Glashaus dass ihre
Innenminister den vergangenen 16 Jahren
gebaut haben ich empfehle Ihnen werfen
Sie jetzt nicht mit Steinen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren die
Koalition stärkt den Bevölkerungsschutz
in Deutschland strukturell wir
überarbeiten die Konzeption zivile
Verteidigung und erarbeiten
entsprechende referenzszenarien mit
Hilfe dieser Erkenntnisse überprüfen wir
die Strukturen und passen die
Ausstattung an Schwachstellen beheben
wir mit den gemeinsamen Kompetenzzentrum
Bevölkerungsschutz sorgen wir für eine
gute Zusammenarbeit von Bund und Ländern
und schon jetzt ist klar dass wir eine
dauerhaften koordinierungsstab für das
Krisenmanagement der Bundesregierung
brauchen nehmen sie weniger von dem was
sie nehmen kann ich nur raten ist gut
für die Gesundheit
wir haben gesehen welche Vorteile der
corona-krisenstab im Kanzleramt gebracht
hat und wir sehen jetzt gerade dass der
koordinierungsstab zum Schutz der
kritischen Infrastruktur ein notwendiges
und wirksames Instrument für eine
wirksames Krisenmanagement der
Bundesregierung ist
die Bundesministerin nennt sie Feser hat
zu Recht gesagt Notlagen bewältigen wir
nur gemeinsam das ist die das ist die
Maßgabe für die Bundesregierung aber
auch für unser Bundestag hier und in der
Not ist die Zuständigkeit sich krank
fehl am Platz in der Katastrophe der
vergangenen Jahrzehnte haben wir jedes
Mal die überwältigende Hilfsbereitschaft
und Solidarität der Bevölkerung gesehen
in jeder Notlage gab es eine
beeindruckende Anzahl professioneller
ehrenamtlicher und
ziviler-katastrophe vom Juli 2021 die
Hilfsbereitschaft im Ahrtal war und ist
gigantisch aber passt das was seit
Jahrzehnten fehlt ist eine effektive
Koordinierung der Hilfe das ist die
Aufgabe die wir lösen werden und sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir haben die
zeitenwände brauchen Bevölkerung für uns
eingeleitet die Koalition ist auch einen
guten Weg
gemeinsam werden wir die vielen Krisen
meistern wenn wir aus den Fehlern der
Vergangenheit lernen und Solidar
zusammenstellen vielen Dank
Ingo Schäfer war das und damit kommen
wir zur letzten Rednerin in dieser
Debatte zum Einzelplan 6 und 21 und das
ist Marlene Schönberger für Bündnis 90
die Grünen im Parlament
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
demokratischen Fraktionen jedes Mal wenn
es zu einer antisemitischen Straftat
kommt sind die Reaktionen die gleichen
es wird verurteilt Solidarität bekundet
und verzügliches Handeln gefordert aber
schnell versinkt alles wieder in
Unbekümmertheit nur für die Betroffenen
für die geht der Alltag weiter mit
Schmerz und Traum unter das schlimmste
ist die Erfahrung zu oft nicht ernst
genommen zu werden das erlebt es in
Frage gestellt wird dass sie alles
wissen muss nicht erkannt wird wenn er
inzwischen Tönen steckt denn anders als
viele denken finden die meisten
antisemitischen Übergriffe unterhalb der
strafbarkeitsgrenze statt z.B wenn
behauptet wird dass Israel
Konzentrationslager bauen würde wenn
Schuhe relativierende witzige gerissen
oder von mächtigen Strippen Tieren
fabuliert wird wenn von der
ausschwitzkeule gesprochen wird wenn mit
letzter Tinte Gedichte geschrieben
werden wenn ein Theaterstück aufge wird
voll von antisemitischen Stereotypen und
chorrelitisierung die Liste ist endlos
und sie beschreibt den Alltag vieler
Jüdinnen Juden und dennoch glauben viele
Menschen dass Antisemitismus ein Problem
der Vergangenheit wäre liebe Kolleginnen
bis vor acht Jahren blieb den
Betroffenen häufig nur die Möglichkeit
auszuhalten oder die Ablehnungsschreiben
von Staatsanwaltschaften zu sammeln denn
die Situation hat sich erst 2015 endlich
verbessert seitdem gibt es RIAS die
Recherche und Informationsstelle
Antisemitismus RIAS ist für viele
Jüdinnen Juden nach
antisemitismuserfahrungen die erste
Anlaufstelle RIAS berät nach
antisemitischen Übergriffen Ria sammelt
Daten die es ermöglicht nach massiv
dieses massive Dunkelfeld an diese
Methodismus zu erhellen über und
Unterhalt der strafbarkeitsgrenze
als Ampel haben wir erkannt Desinteresse
an der Auseinandersetzung mit
Antisemitismus ist ein unhaltbarer
Zustand wir sind gefordert zerstörtes
Vertrauen wieder aufzubauen
dieser Haushalt ist ein weiterer
wichtiger Schritt auf einem langen Weg
wir stellen RIAS im innentar 1,1
Millionen Euro für 2023 bereit denn die
Stärkung der Recherche und
informationsstellungen ist für uns ein
wichtiger Bestandteil bei der Bekämpfung
von Antisemitismus
hinzu
hinzukommen über 20 Millionen Euro mehr
für die Unterstützung jüdischen Lebens
beispielsweise für den Zentralrat der
Juden für den Bau einer Synagoge in
Berlin Wilmersdorf das negativprojekt in
Freundeskreis die etwas Institut
damit
zeigen wir in welche Richtung die Ampel
gehen will klares handeln statt Lehrer
fressen danke schön
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache
wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Einzelplan 06 Bundesministerium ist
Inneren und für Heimat in der
ausschussfassung jetzt liegt hier ein
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
sowie der Fraktion der AFD vor
auf Drucksache
4.548 wer stimmt dafür
die Unionsfraktion wer stimmt dagegen
die über den Fraktion des Hauses kann
Enthaltungen damit ist der
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
abgelehnt Änderungsantrag der Fraktion
der AFD auf Drucksache 4549 wer stimmt
dafür in diesem Antrag erfordert die
afd-fraktion dass ihre Stiftung
Stiftung als parteiener Stiftung der AFD
berücksichtigt wird in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür das
sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer stimmt
dagegen das sind die übrigen abgelehnt
Frau Lötsch hat und die dahinter
nicht abgestimmt
[Musik]
der Linken Fraktion
jetzt sollte eigentlich der Einzelplan 6
abgestimmt werden aber das wird jetzt
noch mal wiederholt
wir kommen zur Abstimmung in den
Einzelplan 06 Bundesministerium ist
Indern und für Heimat in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür das
sind wie gehabt die Koalitionsfraktionen
wer stimmt dagegen das sind nun wer die
übrigen Fraktionen des Hauses damit ist
der Einzelplan nur 6 trotzdem angenommen
Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 21
Bundesbeauftragter für den Datenschutz
und Informationsfreiheit in der
ausschussfassung der stimmt dafür
koalitionsfraktion linke wer stimmt
dagegen die afd-fraktionhaltung keine
damit ist dieser Einzelplan 21 ebenfalls
angenommen